yeah
this is where they're coming I just was
like
[Music]
thank you Mr chairman Commerce Committee
nice to be back you know Mr chairman you
know Mr chairman and I spoke earlier
today because he knows I have to take a
plane tonight and go somewhere so we're
having a nice chat and I'm working late
last night and I'm out of good mood you
know I'm getting all my stuff done so I
can go away for a couple days on
business
and at eight o'clock 808 last night Mr
chairman I get an email that tells me
the speaker has chosen myself
representative Albion scitec for a
condominium committee and I know you had
something to do with it so you know
you've been a great you've been a great
mentor I've been a good student we've
been seat mates
you know we get along pretty well I
don't know what I did to you to receive
anyway thank you Mr chairman I I didn't
have anything else to do but now I do so
thank you
um my name is representative will
infantine I um represent Hillsboro 16 in
Manchester and I'm an insurance agent by
trade but I've been involved with
condominiums for the last 30 years of my
life having owned some as well as being
on the boards of some
and one of the the this I want to give
some background of what this bill is
about
the last time we went through a
recession we had a number of
um condominium associations where they
had units that were foreclosed
and the banks were not doing anything
about it the financial institutions
would not foreclose
and uh the there were no payments for
condo fees being paid by those units
um often more often than not the
association would have to keep those
units heated because you have especially
in townhouses or what have you you have
utilities that go through all of them so
you can't just you know shut off the
heat in one and there was actually a
term coined I think by the Wall Street
Journal called Zombie mortgages
okay where the um the banks wouldn't do
anything about them and you all know if
you've ever
had a mortgage you signed 20 pages and
on each page it tells you all the
terrible things they can do if you're
late by a day or all these other things
that go on
yet when it came down to a situation
um where a unit was for some reason
abandoned uh the people had either lost
their job or divorce or medical issues
and they were no longer in the units
the
financial institutions would not
foreclose
and that harms the rest of the
association
we did have a a sister type of Bill that
was passed by this Committee in the
house a number of years ago which
allowed condominium associations to at
least put a uh a lien on a unit for up
to six months of condo fees because what
would happen is if the unit was vacant
it was abandoned
um the finance of the financial
institution would not pay the condo fees
and as soon as they foreclosed it wiped
it away
and the associations would be out
these fees
actually we came to terms with the uh
the folks at the banking Commission
because they realized
um
that a healthy Association is good for
every lender for every unit so if you
have one or two bad apples it's not good
for the whole
and they did agree to that lean and that
has been a place for the last three
years and I don't think there's been a
uh a hint of any kind of an issue with
that since we put it in place
so this is kind of The Next Step what do
you do when a financial institution will
not foreclose on a property the condo
association continues to pay
and that you know
it's kind of taking from the rest when
they're not doing
uh fulfilling their obligation now
I'm also a nice guy and I don't want
people kicked out of their Condominiums
either
people fall in hard times sometimes it's
very short period of time
so while this bill does not have
it what I'm going to propose in it at
this point if you look on line three of
the bill
Roman numeral 11.
any suit to enforce any lean preferred
under paragraph three
I would add for a condominium abandoned
by the owners I don't want to force this
issue for people that are just trying to
maybe had a short-term situation and are
trying to get their way out of it this
is for people that have said look I'm
sorry for some reason any reason in
their life that they can no longer
afford this and they are leaving they
are taking their stuff they're going and
they're abandoning their unit
I would like to make it that narrow
because
one of the things and we've brought this
bill up in previous years
people have talked about is well you
know you get some people that are behind
by three or four months and you get some
people on a really really
uncomfortable board and they're just
gonna start that foreclosure process on
these people because they're angry with
maybe something else that they did maybe
their dog barks too much or something
like that I don't want this to have
anything to do with that
this is where people have decided that
they can no longer
uh stay there they cannot afford it I do
know this goes on I have a friend of
mine passed away in a car accident four
years ago and I took on his estate
as an executor and he had had some
issues and he had not paid his mortgage
for four years
it took me a court order from the
Hillsborough County Probate Court to get
the bank to take the house back so I
could get on with the estate
they just wouldn't do it
someone someone
finally a law firm in New York they're
actually angry with me when they talked
to the telephone how dare I do that like
well due respect I'm trying to close
this estate he hasn't paid in five years
would you please
take it back
so unfortunately this does happen and
this was three or four years ago when
the economy was fine
um I understand financial institutions
sometimes don't want to put this on
their reports because every time you
have a loan if you know anything about
Bank reports that have to be done by the
feds every quarter you have to list how
many of your loans are 30 you know 60 90
days late and how many are you going to
write off and and I understand in a bad
time they don't want to inundate their
that report to the to the feds uh well
I'm sorry I I get that but you're not
helping the entire situa the entire
condominium and I know my friends at the
the bank banking Lobby are going to be
against me in there I call them my
friends because we usually get along on
everything we usually agree on most
things this one
we're not going to agree on because I do
believe if you have one or two units
that are not paying their fair share the
financial institutions are also not
paying that fair share they're kind of
taking away and making the other unit
owners have to pay for that expense and
I don't think that's right that's what
we're trying to put it into
sorry to bring such a
riveting
um issue to you at 10 A.M but Mr
chairman that is my testimony
okay so um just for a little edification
for the committee members this has been
an issue over many of my many of my
years
of having condo bills come to this
committee and the resolution was really
driven by Fannie Mae
who just who decided that six months was
the right number and so we thought that
was great and we passed that legislation
and it's been on the books for
no fair amount of years yeah
so
what's different I mean Fannie Mae
hasn't changed their mind so why why
would we want to revisit this issue this
is not revisioning that issue Mr
chairman that issue had to do with
condominium fees that were not paid and
it allowed the association to put a lien
for six months worth of condominium fees
in the event of a bankruptcy or
foreclosure by the financial institution
the lien would still be there uh and and
the association would be able to
retrieve some of their money we also
found out that once a lien was placed
usually the institution
um
I don't want to say woke up but you got
an idea what was going on and they
usually tried to address it and more
often than not they paid those six
months
um to get that lien off this is this is
totally different this has to do with
when a unit is vacant it has been
abandoned by the unit owner and the bank
will not foreclose on it and put it back
out for sale it allows the association
to do that when the institution will not
not that I want to you know debate
semantics but this was an issue of super
lean that that you were you would that
the Foreclosure responsibilities the
bank's foreclosure and you are now who
technically you're lean on fees is a
second the condo association's sick and
and so you're you are asking to have to
jump over the bank and to force that
foreclosure when you're technically the
fees are only a second
uh lean rather than the first lean which
I'm pausing only because I want to make
sure I don't say the wrong thing and I
believe what you're saying is correct
but um there will be a an attorney
speaking after me that may be able to
better answer that question for you Mr
chairman
okay
any other questions the committee
I have
rather extensive experience with this
problem
I in the REO world real estate owned uh
so this is not this is a wood you
believe are you asking a question this
is the this is the I think this is uh
the the question that I have for the
petitioner is this
uh
is it my understanding that the intent
of this bill
is to prevent a situation where a bank
may or may not have chosen to foreclose
on a defaulted mortgage where the
property has been abandoned for some
period of time from three months to
three years
and to not allow those homeowners
association dues to accumulate unpaid
yes and no the first part of your
statement yes is to allow the condo
association to bring a foreclosure
um but not necessarily for that three
months to not I think it was a year but
um over a year haven't been paid
um
their fees but it's not necessarily to
collect the fees that's where there's a
difference here the first one was to be
able to collect the fees the bill that
was passed four or five years ago this
is to take an abandoned property into
force a foreclosure when the financial
institution won't so it can then be
brought put back on the market and and
be sold so the next person can own it
and pay their condo fees is this is to
do it when the bank refuses to do
uh to to initiate the Foreclosure so the
the further question may inquire I'm
sorry uh further so the your this this
allows the association to do a
foreclosure is that what we're correct
got it and there's a lot of notice in
here and and that
um there is a law in the Commonwealth of
Massachusetts and some other states so
this is not a novel idea that we're just
trying to bring to to New Hampshire to
see if it works
okay representative Burroughs
thanks for taking my question
um I'm just wondering if
I'm wondering about the about the what
the definition of Abandonment is and
obviously if somebody has cleared out
all their stuff that's a strong
indicator but I'm wondering you know are
there is it is there a set criteria for
this I'm thinking maybe somebody who's
gone off in military duties somebody's
gone off to take care of a elderly
parent maybe gone for months or they're
sick themselves so what protections do
the language I proposed does not define
abandoned if if this is something the
committee is willing to move forward or
with the codicil that it would be only
for abandoned properties I would add a
definition of that
okay uh representative Gibbons
thank you Mr chairman
um I need a clarification and then I'm
going to have to ask for a further
inquiry as well uh first of all for
clarification
um we are discussing HB 178 and the
reason that I ask is because the one
that I read over the weekend and
actually did some research on uh says
nothing about abandonment
um so this is HB 178 and if so could you
tell us again the exact language about
Amendment abandonment that you would add
and and where where you would edit yes
it would be line three of the bill
starts off Roman numeral 11.
a
any suit to enforce any lean perfected
under paragraph three
or a condominium abandoned by the owners
shall be and that's where it would
def that was where it would segregate or
a condo abandoned by the owners okay
um
okay uh and then I I do have a further
question uh yes
um and here I'm just going to
um use some information that I'm
personally familiar with as an example
um on which I base my question
um uh
as I understand the bill and uh some
research I did over the weekend Uh
current legislation provides that a lien
for unpaid condo fees may only be for
six months of unpaid condo fees
um and I live in a condo in Concord uh
and so using my own information as an
example uh six months of condo fees is a
little over two thousand dollars
at the same time uh
the most recent sale of a unit in my
condo development was for more than two
hundred thousand dollars so
this would appear to allow foreclosure
and sale of a two hundred thousand
dollar unit for two thousand dollars of
unpaid condo fees and
um how would you address that and make
sure that you were protecting for
instance individuals
um uh referenced in the earlier question
who might be a way because of military
duty or uh be long-term hospitalized and
perhaps have appeared to abandon their
unit but in fact not have intended to do
so but might be deprived of a two
hundred thousand dollar unit
um for payment for lack of payment of
two thousand dollars
the protocol in the law does not allow
for the association to keep any of the
funds in excess of what they're owed
okay it would go back to the financial
institution the event of foreclosure so
it's not entitled to be a windfall where
hey we get two hundred thousand dollars
for a two thousand dollar
um condo fees that are owed that is not
um the way the whole process works
the comment you make about someone in
military service or someone away
it's a valid point
in an association pretty much everyone
knows what's going on going on with
someone and when someone the association
the board of directors usually knows
I've never heard of a situation where
um at least in Massachusetts where
this this is done
um
very abruptly that people don't know
what's going on and and they know when
the unit is empty is people have moved
out it has been gone for a certain
period of time the association has had
to enter the associate the unit to keep
the heat on and is paying the utilities
under that is usually what happens and
that's when they know it's it's
abandoned and they would utilize this
law
further inquiry further in question you
may inquire thank you uh
my question actually
um was not intended to address the
question of windfall I didn't I do
understand your point about that
um nevertheless uh and sure most of the
time the condo award will know what's
going on but
none of that is perfect
um in order to avoid someone absolutely
losing a two hundred thousand dollar
home regardless of the windfall question
um would you be open to adding a
provision that would allow foreclosure
only when the uh unpaid condo fees were
either a certain dollar amount or a
minimum certain dollar amount or a
minimum percentage of the worth of the
unit in question
maybe the former but not the latter or
it's a certain percentage of the value I
I'd like to not further um answer that
question only because I am not a lawyer
by trade a lawyer will be testifying and
knows the whole protocol of what you
have to do the notifications that need
to be done they're certified letters all
the things the protocols that need to be
done with notifying the bank and
everything else to make sure that you're
not going to do some of the things which
you're you you are fearing that might
happen and I just don't want to muddy
the water when I think a more coherent
answer can come after me
excuse me one more further inquiry
we will be doing a subcommittee so
um very last one I promise okay thank
you
um
uh
and that that all makes sense
um but back to the question of the uh
person who's in the military or in
long-term hospitalization
um while the bank would certainly
receive the notice owners in those
circumstances might not receive the
notice
so how how does that how does that
provision protect the owner
I'm sorry again I'm not trying to
deflect your questions I just know that
someone knows the law the current
protocols the checks and balance is much
better than I who can better answer that
question in a few minutes when I'm
finished testifying and I'm sure they
will because I'm sure they're taking
notes
thank you so uh make sure that person
has a pink card thank you okay
thank you Mr Sharon you mentioned that a
bank might not want to carry this on
their balance sheet so to speak is there
another reason that they might not want
to do a lien or a foreclosure right away
and that they didn't think that they
could resell the property right away but
so is there an option that the bank
could basically start paying for the
electricity the fuel the the condo fees
instead of foreclosing so they could
hold it off for a while but of course in
that case I would assume that they would
I think we would all rather that the
institution financial institutions step
up and pay the condo fees and pay their
utility bills and do that you are spot
on with your
um estimation of what occurred years ago
the
uh appraised values of some of these
Condominiums fell below the uh amount of
the note
and they did not want to put it on the
market until the market recovered
I respect them wanting to do that from a
business decision but again it's all
fair in Love and War here that might be
a good decision for the bank but how
as I understand it one of the purposes
of this bill is to help the condo
association to recoup costs such as
heating costs after a unit is abandoned
because
the association needs to heat that unit
to keep the entire block heated
does the association also continue to
pay heating costs after a unit is
vacated after a voluntary vacate such as
when uh tenants move out
you know it all depends on the situation
um you know not every single Association
is built the same way that it has common
utilities the ones that would yes the
association would have to step in
because they don't want the power to go
off so they would do that but you have
to think of you have 100 units everyone
has 100 1 100th of the obligation to pay
for the Landscaping the plowing uh the
new roofs all the expenses associated
with that Association when one or two
percent those aren't doing it everyone
else has to
um pay the difference
um so that's what we're trying to stop
but direct answer your question it all
depends on how the association's built
and yes the association does have to
take especially for insurance purposes
whatever means necessary to keep it
heated so you don't have frozen pipes
and cause
great thank you very much thank you all
right now we'll hear from the other side
the bankers New Hampshire Bankers
Association
Ryan hill hill and Rob
I guess I should have paid more
attention when you introduced yourself
to me the first one
well good morning
um for the record uh my name is Ryan
Hale uh vice president of government
relations for New Hampshire bankers and
with me today I have Rob diem president
of the Gallagher firm
um uh chairman humble members of the
Commerce Committee
um uh New Hampshire Bankers represents
about 38 represents 38 member banks that
employ nearly 6 000 employees we come
before the committee today to provide
testimony in opposition to House Bill
178 relative to the enforcement of
condominium liens for assessments as
introduced HP 178 would increase
condominium associations current
volunteer condominium boards the right
to foreclose upon and evict
um condominium unit owners for unpaid
assessments and that says currently
written regardless of the amount that's
owed this proposal goes well beyond the
2010 compromise that created existing
statutory priority lien rights for
unpaid assessment fees and allowed
condominium associations to require unit
orders that to Escrow up to six months
of fees if they so choose for committee
members who are returning this all may
sound familiar in 2021 a nearly
identical bill was introduced House Bill
426 this committee unanimously
recommended an expedient to legislate
with an 18-0 vote and then again in 2019
a nearly identical proposal was brought
before the committee HP 436 it also
failed to get your endorsement and was
recommended in expedient to legislate
with 19 nothing vote
again condominium associations already
have less drastic options at their
disposal neither of which would require
such a significant policy change as
already mentioned associations can
require unit owners to Escrow up to six
months of assessment fees providing a
cushion when delinquencies arise
additionally they can limit access to
common areas such as Jim's pools parking
uh to encourage unit owners to pay their
fair share
if enacted hb1 178 is likely to have
significant unintended consequences and
a chilling effect on the condominium
Market specifically if a condominium
board can foreclose upon a unit it will
increase the lenders are members risk
Associates associated with condominium
Lending
this could also result in borrows paying
higher interest rates in an already high
interest rate environment to account for
the added risk or limit access to
lending more generally such consequences
are likely to have impact that extend
beyond the banking industry and could
make Condominiums a less attractive
option for first-time home buyers which
may reduce the values of Condominiums
and could impair an already anemic
housing market by taking options off the
table
there's essential there's also a
substantial question uh as to whether
this Bill runs a foul of Fannie Mae's
eligibility requirements since 2014
Fannie Mae only requires a priority lien
for six months of unpaid assessment fees
under this proposal and others like it
the lien holders would be entitled to
legal fees costs and expenses
why would this impact Banks many sell
their mortgages to the secondary Market
while still maintaining the servicing
rights Fannie Mae is what an entity is
one of the entities Banks use in the
secondary Market adding these fees to
the lien would likely prevent this from
occurring making Condominiums mortgages
riskier for banks to take on possibly
adding to the chilling effect this bill
will have on the market
um I'm going to just address a couple
questions that were raised to the prior
speaker representative Gibbs you made a
actually a great point in the fact that
a Condominium Association this would
allow them to foreclose on uh initiate
the foreclosure for a few thousand
dollars as opposed to the bank's risk
that could be 200 000 in in your in your
association's case
um if not higher
um
uh also as far as the maintenance of the
of the abandoned property uh Fannie Mae
does have a property maintenance Matrix
for the um if a bank has identified a
facility as being abandoned a mortgaged
property as being abandoned or vacant
um so there's certain things they do
they have to do
um I'm happy to provide that Matrix uh
to you all if you'd like uh so in
closing and before I hand it over to Rob
Dieu who would like to share a few
thoughts of his own in closing I would
respectively ask the committee to vote
down HP 178 and recommend inexpedient to
legislate as the committee has done in
the past with similar bills uh thank you
for your consideration and I'll hand it
over to Rob
good morning committee members I'm Rob
dietel I'm with the Gallagher
callahanagar Trail firm here in Concord
and I'm counseled to the bankers
Association as Ryan said this is an
issue that's been bubbling up
um off and on for years a great and
workable compromise was reached in 2010
and I thought I'd share some perspective
there was a case back in 2016 that went
up to the New Hampshire Supreme Court
which I had the privilege of
representing the bankers Association in
and it's called New Hampshire Housing
Finance Authority versus Pinewood or uh
yeah Pinewood Condominium Association
what happened in that case was the
Condominium Association sought to impose
lien rights against actually the New
Hampshire Housing Finance Authority's
interest this isn't always in the
context of banks it can impact anybody
that holds a mortgage
and the Superior Court read our
Condominium Act thought that priority
rights could be obtained
and New Hampshire Housing Finance
Authority appealed and we joined in that
appeal
the New Hampshire Supreme Court looked
at our Condominium Act looked at the
compromise that was put in place in 2010
and found that the six-month priority
lien that exists under state law
represented a very careful balancing
that's necessary to ensure that there's
access to credit for individuals who
want to buy condominiums in the state of
New Hampshire and I want a flag at the
end of their decision and they don't
always do this they included sort of a
discussion about the policy reasons here
and Justice Bassett wrote
are holding today advances the policies
underlying the Condominium Act to rule
otherwise meaning to allow more than six
months priority would create uncertainty
for lenders that provide mortgage
financing to condominium owners the
ability of condominium owners to readily
secure mortgage financing is crucial to
the viability of the condominium form of
ownership improving access to mortgages
for Condominiums allows those who cannot
afford a single-family dwelling to
realize the American dream of home
ownership
this policy principle that they outline
is not um hyperbolic in any way the
standards that Ryan mentioned from
Fannie Mae really come into play here
because when a bank originates a
mortgage loan
they're frequently doing so with the
understanding that they're going to pass
that debt on to a secondary purchaser of
that mortgage and if Fannie Mae is not
standing behind that then that mortgage
is not going to get sold on the
secondary market and as a consequence
there's a trickle-down effect then the
bank won't be in the business of issuing
condominium loans
there's a real real world problem with
that that has a meaningful impact and
representative gibbs's comment about the
the disparity between the amount that
might be owed and the amount owed on the
mortgage is an important one to really
highlight because it's actually worse
than what representative Gibbs said
under this bill it provides and this is
at line 17. the reasonable legal fees
and costs incurred by the unit Owners
Association shall be included as part of
the lien and part of the priority lien
so if we pull back and think about
practically speaking what could happen
here you could have a condominium board
that's frustrated with a unit owner
wants to get them out wants to foreclose
is owed a couple thousand dollars and
goes into court hires an attorney and
the attorney says to the board there's
no skin off your back I'm going to be
able to collect my attorney's fees
against the mortgage
and then they go into court and they
potentially foreclose for two thousand
dollars maybe rack up tens of thousands
in legal fees and then all of that comes
out from a priority position against the
bank
that is a real problem and there's no
checks and balances right now in this in
this bill as drafted to prevent that
type of scenario from occurring so I
hope that information is helpful if
there's any questions I'm happy to take
them
I'm not a banker and I'm not a lawyer
so I may not see the nuances of
something but if we did change the words
the way the sponsor indicated and said
this can only happen in the case of an
abandonment we're not talking about
for closing for two thousand dollars in
fees we're talking about a condo that's
been abandoned and the association now
says all right we've carried this long
enough and a definition of what long
enough an abandonment is needs to be
defined
does that ease up any of this
potentially
um and I say potentially because the the
devil's in the details right
um so we have to there'd have to be
meaningful safeguards in place to make
sure that the proper parties are being
noticed there'd have to be evaluation
from my perspective on the timelines and
the amounts that would trigger this sort
of event to occur but there would also
have to be thought given to this
priority position
um the language that's in there because
it it encourages the tail wagging the
dog so to speak right
um and so long as the condo association
can get priority of both more than six
months attorneys fees all of that you're
gonna be stuck with the same problem
that the secondary Market might not
accept these loans
and beyond that you may have a scenario
where a small amount throws them to a
large amount through attorneys fees and
really creates an inequitable balance so
it's doable but there's a lot along the
way
okay
Mr chairman thank you gentlemen
so uh
with respect to the issue of
the condo association not being happy
because it's not receiving its fees
would a situation exist such that
the lender would not be receiving or
would be receiving payments at that time
um
such that the lender would be
disinclined to move to foreclose because
the lender was actually receiving shall
we say mortgage payments
um and in general what are the factors
that would lead you to foreclose or not
foreclose in addition to the
illustration which has already been
cited where a condo unit may actually be
appraised at a value less than the
original mortgage amount I hope that
those two questions are distinct enough
so you can answer both of them yeah I
think you can well
for there could be a variety of reasons
why the bank's not foreclosing I think
one uh would be that they're trying to
work something out with the home buyer
you know maybe providing some loan
modification to to get them through uh
the last thing a bank wants to do is
foreclose it's really the last tool in
the toolbox
um because again there's a lot at stake
here it's a it's a high risk they don't
want to
um they want to keep that individual in
their home I think we saw that through
the covet pandemic and all the
forbearance programs that were going on
to really make sure that homeowner again
a lot that was required but Banks were
doing that prior it's what they do they
want to make sure that the mortgagee is
um is being is in their home and trying
to work through it
um Rob I don't know if you have anything
else you'd like to add so I with respect
to the first question please yeah I
think that's a fair summary Ryan there's
there's as Ryan said there's a lot of
reasons why a bank might not be
foreclosing one of the principal reasons
might be that they may not even be aware
that there are delinquencies outstanding
in the condominium assessments
um and and this is this goes back to the
policy issues we were talking about
before part of the reason why
six months priority lien rights were
created to give condominium associations
that right is it reflects an
understanding that condominium boards
are in the best position to understand
if there's a problem with a unit owner
if they're becoming delinquent
um banks are not always going to be
aware of what's going on boots on the
ground at the Condominium Association
um and that dovetails into it's not just
a priority lean right that was created
as Ryan mentioned in his remarks there's
a right to Escrow Condominium
Association dues so these things are
intended to work in concert with each
other so if you're a board and you've
got an individual who you're foreseeing
a problem you can go to them and say
look we've had some issues with your
payments we want you to Escrow six
months worth of condominium assessments
but what's happened and this is just a
practical observation so I'm a
practicing lawyer I'm often defending
individuals and companies in court I've
had condo associations call me up and
they'll say we've got a delinquent owner
what do we do and I'll ask them well did
you put in place the six-month priority
lien and almost always the answer is no
and it's not because that lean right
isn't working it's because of the
realities of a Condominium Association
you have volunteer boards and you have
most condo associations are small
they're not 100 units they're 20 or 10
units and you know the people personally
and individually and I think there's a
human nature aspect of perhaps not
wanting to be aggressive and going after
them
but those are decisions that are being
made by the condo association that the
bank can't control or be a part of in
any meaningful way so I hope that's
helpful
further question oh thank you so so in
fact there may be there are situations
where condo owners are making their
mortgage payments but not making their
paying their condo fees
which is what I think I heard when you
said we're not even aware of there being
a problem and I infer from that that
you're saying that you're the bank is
being paid
and it turns out that at the same time
the condo owner is not paying his or her
condo fees is yes or no
in some scenarios yes in some scenarios
no and what's more nuanced than that is
that sometimes these disputes the reason
why they're not being paid is not a
financial reason sometimes it's we don't
think that that contract with the guy
who mows the lawn was a good contract
and the board is mismanaging it there's
a lot of personality in human nature
that comes into these thank you missions
representative
um my my question to the previous uh
speaker was whether the bank can uh or
will pay uh you know the electric bill
the fuel Bill and whatever and uh you
mentioned the uh Fannie Mae Matrix so is
it do I understand that that's required
in order to sell that mortgage into the
secondary Market could you explain a
little bit further
so general what happens is when the bank
makes the mortgage
um and they sell it off to the secondary
Market they still own the servicing
they'll they'll maintain the servicing
rates so they they bill they they bill
the customer
um and when the bank under the agreement
with Fannie Mae as a servicer when
they've identified that the property is
vacant and abandoned
um there they have this obligation to
maintain this property through this
property maintenance guide
great thank you very much oh
Jeff representative Sullivan
thank you Mr chairman
um so yeah one of the things that you've
mentioned is the potential for a
trickle-down chilling effect on the
condo Market I'm curious since there are
other states that have similar types of
laws if we see any evidence of that
actually happening seems like a perfect
natural experiment between Massachusetts
and here to see if there's a big Delta
between single-family homes and condos
in
Massachusetts that doesn't exist in New
Hampshire because of a regulation
well what I would say in Ryan certainly
step in if you have more timely
information than I do is unfortunately I
don't know the specific answer that
question and I'm not sure it actually is
answerable and the reason why I say that
is because these condo acts are fitting
within the Matrix of whatever the laws
are in place so for instance New
Hampshire foreclosures are generally not
judicial foreclosures their power of
sale foreclosures another jurisdiction
might have a Judicial foreclosure system
they might have different mechanisms
that enable condo associations to be
more proactive or not
and so and and beyond that Fannie Mae
has standards that are time based so if
laws were enacted prior to 2014
Fannie Mae will recognize those if
they're enacted after 2014 they do not
that goes down to reasons of notice and
takings and things along those lines but
it's very hard to compare apples to
yeah my memory was when we did this bill
12 years ago maybe I'm going to ask Tara
Reardon and she remember so I remember
we did get a piece of paper that said
the Massachusetts rate interest rates
were three quarters higher
I remember never getting it back down
so anyway
thank you very much
and I do have testimony that written
testimony that I'll hand out good
that'll make the clerk happy
do I need to hit this button yes of
course
red is good thank you red means stop I
thought um
good morning my name is Eric Shaughnessy
I'm an attorney I represent condo
associations in New Hampshire and in
Massachusetts and I'm speaking in
support of this bill I'm also a member
of Community Association Institute of
New England Cai there's another member
from that group that will be speaking so
I'm going to address I'm going to leave
some things to him and I'm addressing
some things from uh from what I've heard
and I want to start by actually doing a
little comparison because there were
some questions asked about other states
and how they operate
and
I'm just going to highlight it's our
neighbor Massachusetts
they have a priority lien that can be
any number of months not six not 12 not
18 it can Theory be any number of months
and they have the ability to foreclose
and we see no chilling effect on sales
of condo units throughout the state
so from a practitioner's standpoint we
see no problem in terms of units being
sold all the time and the fact that
Massachusetts can have 6 12 18 months of
priority lien has not stopped
uh the secondary Market from happening
and
the representatives from the on the
banking side you'd like to use terms
such as likely and maybe very
non-definitive terms
to suggest that there could be in theory
a possible issue I just want to
highlight that we see as from a
practitioner standpoint actual problems
Within These communities where you have
unit owners who for whatever reason
choose not to issue payment of the condo
fees which then places the financial
burden on the remainder of the community
to carry that
and to carry it for an extended period
of time
that is inherently unfair to the rest of
the community this bill is simply
seeking to create a uniform mechanism to
solve that problem it does not create
more than six months worth of priority
lien it's still six months if there's a
priority lien you have the right to
foreclose if there's no priority you
still have the right to foreclose but it
doesn't go from six months to 18 months
or from 6 to 12 it stays at six that
number doesn't change throughout the
course of this process
and in terms of the safeguards that were
mentioned
talked about in the form of notices
for a practitioner such as myself to go
to to get this priority in theory to
foreclose we have to send notice to the
owner we have to send multiple notices
to the mortgage company we have to file
a lawsuit we have to serve that lawsuit
on the unit owner and the mortgage
company we'd have to file all our
paperwork at the court serve that
paperwork including motions for judgment
on all the parties then hold a hearing
where the other side the bank the unit
owner has the opportunity to be heard in
court and then the court the judge will
have to rule on the issue and Grant
judgment and allow the association to
move forward so this isn't as if we send
one piece of paper out the door and all
of a sudden we can go foreclose there's
an extended long process to get to the
end point wherein many of these
safeguards mentioned are hit repeated
notices throughout the entirety of the
process is when the when the bankers say
well we don't know what's happening we
let them know multiple times and giving
them multiple opportunities to address
the issue which they have the right to
do and they have to make a decision
either to address it or not to address
it it's not a lack of notice or lack of
being informed it's an internal decision
whether they address it and respond
so
with that I'm happy to take some
questions that may exist but that is the
process it is it is not overnight it is
long it is slow
and this bill seeks to create a formal a
unified process to address really those
representative Sullivan
thank you Mr chairman
um so I I'll ask a similar question I
asked them you could because you
mentioned it you seem to think that
there is no chilling effect in the
secondary Market in Massachusetts are
you saying that because people are able
to do it are you saying that there is no
spread between maybe what's happening in
New Hampshire in here or what's
happening in single family versus here
what I can say is from my perspective on
what I see I see no issue no problem in
uh mortgages being assigned because we
look in the registry of deeds we follow
the title to the property when we do
this we see it all assigned all the time
we deal with Services all the time I
don't from my perspective from what I
see I do not see and I'm not a blender
so I can't speak on their behalf but I
do not see anything that indicates that
there's an inability
follow up for the question you may
inquire um okay but be clear you're not
sure if there is a a larger spread in
the condo to single-family Market in say
Massachusetts which has this law versus
State of New Hampshire
um or if you were to compare those two
spreads in the two states like there's
ways to get at this I'm just wondering
if you know that I personally do not
know that and I cannot say definitively
um okay thank you
representative Herbert did you have a
question
I think you might have just answered the
question I wanted you represent mass and
also New Hampshire is there any any uh
distinction or difference in the system
in New Hampshire that uh uh informs you
uh when you because you were talking
about Massachusetts most of the time I'm
talking about both States so
right now in Massachusetts so we
understand it
to effectuate a priority lien we have to
send a series of notices to the unit
owner and to the mortgage company and in
that sense it's exactly the same as New
Hampshire those processes are pretty
identical
from that point in Massachusetts we
file a lawsuit we serve it on the
parties and we seek judgment we go to
court the court grants the Judgment
possibly and from there we're allowed to
foreclose and in Massachusetts we're
allowed to add more than six months New
Hampshire right now
we send those same notices we then
record what's called a membrane of a
lien and then we can file the lawsuit
and from there we can go to court get a
judgment
and then from that we can exercise a
Sheriff sale or some other mechanism to
try to get to the end goal which is a
more prolonged process
so
um I guess to answer your question I'm
not just talking about Massachusetts the
states that have a big distinction in it
there's a huge separation at the point
following the notices being sent
I guess my question
I so my question is essentially
is there a problem
in your opinion between what New
Hampshire has now or if they put a
six-month limit is there a problem or an
issue there that uh would tell me as a
legislator
this is not a good idea what something
else should be done because
Massachusetts has a multiple
I'm trying to figure out whether we
should be doing anything and I want your
opinion sure yes my opinion is there is
a problem there's an inability for these
communities to resolve Perpetual
non-payment historical non-payers that
that you'll have literally years of
condo fees owed because there's no good
solution in the pocket for the
association the idea of getting six
months paid up front doesn't make sense
when the owner is not going to pay
already we can't say please pay us six
more months if they're not going to pay
us the existing six months so there
there is a problem that this bill seeks
to solve which is addressing the
habitual non-payer and um and thus
stopping the burden being picked up by
the rest of the community
thank you
uh
the sponsor when he spoke said that the
attorney could address some of the
questions about the imbalance between
the that's a different attorney I'm
sorry yeah that's somebody else that he
wants
ah but go ahead ask her a question but
my apologies I screwed up but perhaps
perhaps nevertheless you can help answer
this question
um
back to the imbalance that I referenced
in my question to the sponsor
um
there have been there's been some
discussion about the limitation of the
unpaid fees lien to six months
um as being an advantage in the mortgage
market and I can see where that could be
true
um but the result is still that
the
again assuming that this doesn't this
bill isn't changed so that it applies
only to really abandoned units where
uh everybody including the owner who's
away in Iraq or wherever it might be uh
would would have noticed
um
uh
that the uh that the two hundred
thousand dollar unit would be lost and
I'm not talking about the loss to the
bank and I'm not talking about windfall
profit I'm talking about someone coming
home from say a long-term military
deployment or a long-term uh
hospitalization and discovering that
they have lost their home
um which is worth two hundred thousand
dollars uh because of two thousand
dollars in unpaid condo fees
um
can you
address that issue sure I'll I'll do my
best
I'm not aware of any situation like that
ever occurring
um there are safeguards for people in
the military where we don't have the
right to foreclose on them which would
apply in this case I believe and
um we also have an obligation to serve
individuals
right we have to go to court and we have
to effectuate proper good service of the
complaint upon the individuals and if we
cannot do that if we cannot make the
person an image individuals aware of the
lawsuit that's pending we have no right
to judgment in the courts
so there are safeguards in place where
that outcome should never transpire
one further inquiry
okay thank you uh
would you see a problem in including a
change to this bill providing either a
minimum dollar amount or a minimum
percentage of the value of the unit in
unpaid condo fees before foreclosure and
sale would be an available option
yes I see a problem that because it it
really restricts the the effectiveness
of this if you have a unit that's worth
a million dollars
and the condo fees for this Association
are 250 dollars
how many years do we have to get before
we hit that threshold how many years of
the rest of the community have to carry
the burden for the remainder of the
owners so I do have a problem with that
I think the practically speaking we
don't see uh that issue I just don't see
um
who
you were but by I guess creating a
percentage or minimum dollar amount
we're ignoring
what the condo fees are per month
um per se because you have some
communities with higher fees and some
with lower fees and and the value is it
the same right you could have a condo
unit that's worth two hundred thousand
dollars and the condo fees are 100 a
month and you have one where the condo
fees are 500 a month the valuation
doesn't change and why should the rights
be different under those two
circumstances I think a more uniform
great thank you very much thank you all
right so Gary you get you get shuffled
down yes come on up
so Gary daddario's which represents
Cai
uh good morning uh as the chairman
mentioned my name is Gary jadario I'm
also a condominium attorney I'm a
partner at the law firm of Marcus Rico
Ameren Brooks we represent associations
in several States throughout New England
um I'm going to start by addressing the
what I'll call the Deja Vu issue uh yes
we've been here before with this bill uh
yes it hasn't passed to date the reason
why we're back isn't because we like
doing this it's not because we are
willing to waste our time it's not
because we want to waste your time it's
because the need is still there for
these associations and if anything as
the years march on that need for this
law to be in place is increasing and
that's why we're here along those lines
I will tell you that I have been
focusing my practice in condominium and
Association law for the past 20 years
and what I'm seeing lately are things
that I've never seen before I'm seeing
associations with their year-end
financials year end no more movement no
more play are showing that they have
operated at a deficit for the year
simple mathematics tells us
associations can't do that indefinitely
they need to be able to pay their bills
and as you've heard a lot of this might
be utilities it might be the heat that's
keeping the pipes from freezing in the
winter but it's also the insurance on
the property and as I think most of you
know the insurance company's not going
to have a problem canceling that policy
if the premiums aren't paid so the idea
that associations don't have enough
money to pay their bills is a serious
problem and it's a serious problem for
everyone including the lenders
I would point out to this committee that
you have in the existing law of this
state
uh budget process and a special
assessment process that allow
communities by a two-thirds vote to
reject what is proposed by their board
so understand please that when an
association is operating at a deficit
under the law it's not even as simple as
boards saying with
we have a shortfall unfortunately we're
going to have to make another assessment
to catch up on our money because if they
try to do that the community can simply
show up and say thanks but no thanks we
don't want another assessment and now
the assessment is rejected
so boards are being put you know between
a rock and a hard place to to use a
cliche expression
um and they really need some assistance
here uh you've heard a lot about the
inequities that result when some folks
are paying in the community and some
folks are not I'm going to use some
harshar terminology I think what you
have in those instances is you have
forced private subsidized housing
because if I'm paying my condo fees and
any one of you are my neighbors you
might be right on the other side of the
wall and you're not paying your condo
fees and this is going on for years at a
time I and the other owners who are
paying the condo fees are make no
mistake about it we are subsidizing your
life and your investment in this piece
of Real Estate
and it's not fair when you consider that
these are all private parties in the
point of the association is to be
sharing in the expenses
so again there's a very real problem
that needs to be solved for the benefit
of all who are there you've heard that
there are possible negative consequences
to the market there's been a fair amount
of discussion of that
um I'd like to add some information for
you in that respect
Cai
on uh behalf of which I'm speaking today
and those letters by the way stand for
the community associations Institute
they are nationwide non-profit whose
existence is solely to make Association
living better that's the only thing they
ever try to do that's why they exist
because they operate on a national basis
they keep tabs on everything on a
national basis just so that you're aware
there are 21 states and two we'll say
districts who have priority liens
um
of all of them
any association in any of those places
with the sole exception of New Hampshire
can foreclose on their priority link
so to be clear again what you have in
terms of does it work does it break down
the market if we do this is there going
to be a problem is there a problem
elsewhere
in response to all of those questions
know that there are 20 States
that allow associations a priority lien
and the ability to foreclose on it that
is also true of the District of Columbia
it is also true of Puerto Rico
New Hampshire is the only state that has
a priority lien where we are still
trying
to be able to have the association have
a right under the law to foreclose on
that lien
now you've also heard some testimony and
asked some questions about the process
in the concerns of the process is it
going to happen too fast is it going to
happen for too little money is it going
to Prejudice anybody who doesn't know
about it
and I would say to you that the answers
to those questions are no
again under existing law associations
are filing their lien they're perfecting
their priority lien with six months owed
so no one's foreclosing on three months
no one's even foreclosing on six months
because at the six month marker they are
filing their priority lien in recording
their memorandum of lean with the
registry of deeds so now six months are
owed what happens next next if the
association isn't paid then they file
their lawsuit
when the lawsuits filed there's a
three-month period to achieve service of
process
that's where we get into the issues of
uh has the lender
received their service a process by the
way the lender is entitled to not one
but two notices prior to the filing of
the suit so again the lender is going to
be keenly aware of the situation two
notices prior to suit then suit is filed
now we're at the six month Mark now
there's three months for service a
process during which time the lender is
being served the unit owner is being
served
um here's where we get into concerns
about military and so on uh someone
who's deployed in the military we're not
going to achieve service a process on
them and as attorney Shaughnessy
mentioned to you then the suit is going
to stop
because the court doesn't go forward
when you don't have service a process on
the defendant
but let's assume that service is made
at that point the defendant has a month
give or take to answer to the complaint
after that month goes by and if an
answer is filed uh now we get into
motions that get filed in the case
whether they be for judgment or
otherwise as was mentioned to you a
hearing needs to be scheduled that gets
scheduled uh you know according to the
court and unfortunately most attorneys
will tell you that you know we wish uh
hearings would come sooner than they do
but the courts are busy so it takes time
after the hearing there's some time that
passes while the Court decides what they
want to do with the case before they
issue the Judgment when they do issue
the judgment
again the defendant has a month give or
take to make payment on that judgment
before anybody can try to further the
process so to be clear uh when we're
talking about foreclosure in a
condominium case we're not talking about
two thousand dollars for six months of
condo fees that was when the lien was
filed then we got into the lawsuit then
service a process then the litigation
then the time for the hearing then the
judgment and so on foreclosure hasn't
happened in the 20 years that I've been
practicing I don't think I've ever seen
a condominium unit go to foreclosure in
this state or in Massachusetts where I
also practice I don't think I've seen a
unit go to foreclosure or in this case
Sheriff sale in New Hampshire in less
than a year's time and usually it's more
than that
to address for you the concerns about
legal fees again I cannot speak for
myself I can't speak for all attorneys
but
um tens of thousands of attorney fees
for the association in these cases no
not not for me ever in 20 years I've
never had fees of tens of thousands of
dollars even to foreclose on a unit if
the case ever goes that far and by the
way keeping stats on my practice as I do
in that 20 years time less than three
percent in the jurisdiction where I
could foreclose where the association
has the right to foreclose on a unit
less than three percent of all of my
cases ever reach that point
why is that well for one thing when you
can foreclose
now you have the ability to say this
case is going to end one way or the
other
and guess what some of those unit owners
when they're faced with that situation
will do what they need to do
to pay the association maybe it means
taking out a loan or another mortgage
maybe it means you know in the worst
cases that they allow something else to
fall a little behind because the day has
come to pay the association if things
are tight but they make something happen
alternatively the bank the lender in the
situation can make something happen not
the least of which by the way is that
they have the right and by the way
that's why they get the notices in the
first place
they have the right to make payments of
the assessments in in the standard
condominium Rider that goes with the
mortgages that they issue when folks are
buying these units it allows them if
they have to pay the association the
condo fees on the internet's behalf it
allows them to add that to the balance
of the mortgage
so ultimately that money is collectible
for them in the end the bank isn't
paying it out of their pocket they're
paying it as part of the debt of the
unit owner they have that option
um speaking of options of the bank or
lender as the case may be
um I would like to note that they have
options at the beginning options that
that never exist for the association
meaning that they pass judgment on the
applications that they receive they have
the ability to look over an application
and say we are approving this loan which
I assume they do when they feel
confident that they will be paid back
but conversely if they decide that they
don't want to give that loan they simply
reject that loan the association on the
other hand regardless of of what
Association we might be talking about
when a unit owner buys a unit
that's it no judgment call they're a
member of the association now and the
association is forced to deal with them
and if they're someone who doesn't pay
their bills then the association ends up
with a problem potentially a long-term
problem
and you know this foreclosure remedy as
you've heard before I can tell you for
all the associations I represent it
would be a last effort measure that you
would undertake in a case that just
didn't resolve by any other means that's
what it is you heard about the
association's other remedies they will
try those sometimes uh you know the
balance is paid because a lien gets
recorded on the on the unit and if that
balance is paid then that's great then
the case ends sometimes they're paid
because a judgment issued from the court
if so that's great then the case ends
you heard about
ceasing services to delinquent unit
owners the law does in New Hampshire
afford associations that right however
in the worst of these cases the unit
owners are not even at these units
they've either abandoned them or they
live elsewhere because this was
investment property they may even have
tenants in these units the point is if
they've decided to be a long-term
delinquent and if they're not on the
property and the association says no
more access to the pool for you
they simply do not care
and in the cases where they're refusing
to pay a court judgment doesn't make
them pay denying them access to the pool
isn't fruitful time has gone on you're
now over a year you might be at two
years then a really big question arises
and it's a difficult conversation for me
every single time when my clients say to
me how are we going to end this
and unfortunately under New Hampshire
law right now there isn't a good way to
bring any finality to the situation
and I would suggest to you that by
allowing associations to foreclose at
the end of a legal process where
everyone has noticed
it just isn't unfair it just isn't what
it is is it's fair to everyone else in
the association who is trying to meet
those responsibilities the financial
obligations that they all have
I will stop there I know we're having
issues with time and I want to make sure
that uh there can be questions if there
are any
I think they're all questioned out thank
you okay thank you got one more card
foreign
my name is Lee Greenwood I represent a
Socia associate is a the largest
national
um Association Management Company in the
country we represent condos that manage
condo associations HOAs Etc we have been
active in New Hampshire for for over
four decades now we're a large presence
here we manage over make sure I get
these stats right about 25 000 units we
have about 150 employees in the granite
state
um so we've worked here for a while and
and I Gary's still a lot of my thunder
so I'm going to be brief I promise you
all and did it much better than I ever
appreciated yes of course um but
honestly what this bill comes down to to
me is is two words equity and fairness
um words that we hear a lot today uh
around us and when I say that I I mean
in a couple of ways but but the main way
is that as Gary sort of alluded to an
association is a is a community right
and and that Community is made up of
individual unit owners that have entered
into a contract with the association so
every time they buy into that
Association they make they sign a
contract agreeing to pay their
assessments now the board of the
association of course creates a budget
pays fees Insurance maintenance the pool
if there is one
Etc and all of those fees as as for all
of us have to be paid for somehow so in
the cases where there is a delinquent
owner
those fees don't just get absorbed into
the air they have to be made up one way
or the other and and the way that
they're made up is is that the other
unit owners have to pay more and that to
me and and I think to a lot of us is
just an unfair inequate inequitable way
of dealing with the situation if if 99
of the people are are paying every month
as they're supposed to and as they're
contractually obligated to but one
percent isn't that's not fair for the 99
percent
um and as Gary said foreclosure is of
course a last resort
um as it is in in the 21 other state or
20 other states that have super lean
priority
um and also the Washington DC and Puerto
Rico so it really does come down to that
fairness issue
um and then just I just want to very
briefly mention um you know our our
friends in the banking Community
mentioned that that the the numbers that
we're talking about when when we're
talking about missed assessments or
delinquent assessments certainly dwarf
compared to typically dwarf compared to
what a mortgage holder would have but
you know let's think about that in scale
the numbers while it might be a few
thousand dollars a few thousand dollars
to an association really is the
difference between running your
Association or or not being able to pay
your bills so so yes it might be a
larger number on in some other kind of
liens but but in an association where
you have as few as a handful of unit
owners or as many as you know a couple
of hundred that really those numbers do
add up very quickly and as far as the
chilling effect
um concerns I I would just say that the
20 as Gary said in in 20 other states in
in DC and Puerto Rico the the condo
Market is robust people are are buying
and selling their condos I mean I am one
of them I live in Massachusetts I sorry
about that but I I live in Massachusetts
and I'm a condo owner and and you know I
can I can say that the market is robust
I don't have the data
um but but I I certainly know that that
those markets are are flourishing as and
those associations are doing well so I
will leave it there but I just did want
to leave one other thing with you all um
that then these numbers were kind of
shocking to me when I first saw them but
as of about a year year and a half ago
there are 267
000 New Hampshire residents who live in
an association of one form or another in
HOA a condo
um and that's roughly 20 percent of the
folks living in New Hampshire the
population of New Hampshire so this is a
housing model that that is growing that
people are are happy in and that uh you
know a large number of New Hampshire
residents have are have chosen to to buy
into so this is an important bill for us
we would uh we certainly would urge the
community to support it and and report
it out
great uh representative fieldott has a
question
thank you Mr chairman just a question
that was actually raised to me from your
your colleague it some of these units
will be investment properties in which
you actually have tenants who are not
the ones who are directly paying the
mortgage how would this law and the
eviction mechanism in this law interact
with federal law such as the protection
of tenants at eviction act and how do
these two overlay as you've seen in
other states with this type of provision
so I'm not really sure the answer to
that to be honest with you um I think I
would ask one of our attorney friends do
you do you have an answer that you can
uh the the question was so
how would they this type of provision
overlay with Federal protections for uh
tenants who are living in an investment
property such as the Federal Protection
of tenants at eviction act and is there
is there an introduction between this
tell you what why don't you think about
the answer for that one and then send an
email and to the committee to respond to
it well definitely but we'll so at least
when we take it up by the subcommittee
we'll hopefully get an answer to that
question
a short answer for now I don't think
there is a formal interplay because it's
named what we're talking about are
relatively new Provisions
um and by the way obviously my classes
towards associations that I spend my
career trying to help but all of these
new Provisions
um you know while I'm not looking for
people to be thrown out on the street
that's not my thing but to the extent
unfortunately you don't have a mic and
so we'll just have to well wait send us
I submitted my written testimony to the
clerk this morning so okay great thank
you very much thank you all right having
no more cards I apologize representative
Almy will close this public hearing and
open up the next one
in House Bill 239
um
Lucy
okay I'm a representative Susan Almy
city of Lebanon Grafton 17. it's hard to
remember the number
and I've been
um I started the condominium committee
and I've been on it all but one term
since then so you may be seeing me again
uh
in fact next year for sure you will be
seeing me again with the bill that we
keep trying to get past but
um I'm here today on behalf of
a man who lives in Massachusetts and has
a condominium in Lincoln
and he is a
representative of the very large group
of second homeowners in condominiums in
our state and they do pay property tax
and on
he has pointed out to me something that
I hadn't thought about before
in on
on representative Webb bought brought in
a bill which said I can't manage to get
details about the budget and what's
going on in my Condominium Association I
want you to change the law
and you and
um
my committee to some extent also
statutory committee on
worked on the language some and we came
up with what is in uh a was in HB 502 as
it was enacted and that is the first
three pages that you're looking at for
some reason the copiers decide to put my
testimony on the back
um
and uh he pointed out to me that
on there is nothing in the law that
requires condominium to produce any kind
of a reviewer audit of the finances and
hand them to the members there is in
some bylaws including in his but uh his
condominium has been creative about of
reinterpreting
the bylaws as well as the law that we
produced in 2017.
so um
it's too easy in the condominium world
for boards or their property managers to
hide problems in the finances of their
operation particularly when most of the
owners are second homeowners and not
present
the legislature took this stab at it
um
in 2017
condo owners should be able to get
sufficient information to know whether
their investment and for many of them
their residents is in trouble
when it isn't which is usually the case
that's fine
on when there is a case of mismanagement
or Worse the owner has the documentary
proof that can
that has the documentary proof can form
a group to demand changes to take over
the board to correct the problem or to
go to court equipped to prove the case
and you have seen some of those come
here to testify in past terms and I have
seen more of them there was another
board in Plymouth switch without the any
information to their members on
on loaned provided got a loan from the
local bank to pay for
overages in their expenses which were
above special assessments that they'd
done that they then used for other
purposes
and they gave the bank total control
over the checkbook of the of the
Condominium Association the bank was
receiving the deposits in the bank was
uh was okaying the expenses and this was
totally unknown to the people in the
condominium most of whom were second
homeowners and I was contacted by a
woman and spent the summer uh going
through the Grafton registry of deeds to
find these Bank contracts that they knew
nothing about which then helped that
woman to get the second homeowners
together to to confront the board and
get this solved
so um this kind of thing does happen
I hope it's rare it we found out a fair
number of them in those of us that have
been on the condo board for more than
a condo committee for more than a term
um
because people come to us
but then people either decide that they
can't handle this and they're selling
out no leaving New Hampshire
or they come to us and and we kind of
participate with them as they solve the
problem and then they don't come back to
talk to you about it again after the
first two years so on this
it does take years of met of
mismanagement sometimes for the for the
owners to begin to recognize that
there's something wrong with their
investment
um and
but it would be much better to do a real
independent audit every year or every
few years to reassure the owners
on we do not now require any kind of
independent audit whether the kind my
complex does by hiring an independent
accountant actually to check our bank
statements against our bills
or the very thorough kind that Mr Bob
simck behind me is proposing
his small Association is run through the
board by an external manager who audits
himself
and then says everything's fine
Mr simic has spent years trying to use
our uh
37 e on
two to demand an independent and
thorough examination of the books
the board has denied him he has hired a
lawyer and a CPA to help him uh I bring
you this bill because I think that it
seems likely it would make it easier to
get this audit or to convince a court to
requirement with language that more
closely follows the auditing process
the bill Builds on the 2017 law
it expands on the second section
the first part on which we've relabeled
on I'm Roman 2A treats the information
specified in 2017 is a subset of all the
relevant financial data that should be
made available to an inquiring member
right now it talks about contracts
mortgages on debts long-term commitments
and that has been very important in some
cases that I've dealt with before but it
does not talk about the current
um
um the on
accounts of the association and the bank
statements
which can give you an idea if there is
something strange going on in in the
finances uh section Roman 2B adds a
requirement that every condominium board
should be providing the members with an
independent review of all books and
records at least once every three years
this is purposely vague enough that it
could be done at minor expense
uh in my Association we've got 22 mem to
owners on it is
um
it's done annually for three hundred
dollars just checking the bank
statements against the billing
uh
and uh it goes on to say that any owner
or owners at their own expense will have
access to do a more detailed audit as
long as such an audit has not been done
within the last three years so it
protects from
the kind of member who
watch every single detail of the
association's life for for every single
month which I experienced early in my
time in Condominiums
on but it
does say that every within every once
every three years if a member or their
members thinks that there is something
strange going on can get a real audit
but they'll have to pay for it
on Romans 3 C
uh 2C keeps the second part of the
original language about privacy of
individual owners accounts but adds that
the auditor with adequate privacy
protection should be able to see those
accounts
I had one case recently where a woman
was in a four-person condominium and
when she moved in after she moved in she
realized that she was paying a lot more
than any of the other three people
foreign
and that two of the people had been put
in there specifically by the owner for
that purpose
so on
this is
um I I just like to end there but ask
you to call on Mr simic next and then
the others so that he can explain better
than I can
I'm not understanding the difference
between 2A oh I just lost it I'm sorry
the paragraph after that and 2B so 2B is
saying that you know every three years
we can have an audit and if you want
additional details you know you would
pay for that
to a is kind of indicating that
they have access to all kinds of things
are you saying that an owner can ask
the condo association to start printing
out
reams of information that on a whim just
because they want it
and I experienced this when I was first
in a condo association after I came back
to this country on and it was a neighbor
a new neighbor of mine and yes he he was
insisting on printouts this does not
mention printouts it says access to what
do you mean by access just that you have
to make the books available or yes that
on that person can go to your office and
on and check
the financial books
in the case where you talk about owners
being out of state
yes and that that is somewhat of a
problem that when the owners only arrive
on weekends and uh frankly
um
I would hope that an owner that cared
that much about it could come on on a
weekday what has happened with the
gentleman behind me is that he set up in
a a time to come and meet they told him
he had an hour they spent 40 minutes of
it with his lawyer arguing about whether
they had to do it and then said you've
only got 20 minutes left
foreign
normally the procedurally we would uh
have uh a representative who wants to
good morning and thank you appreciate
having the opportunity to uh to speak
with you all my name is Bob simack I'm a
condominium unit owner at the loonwood
Village 2 Condominium Association uh in
Lincoln that's over on the side of Loon
Mountain
I am
a small business owner I run an oncology
nutrition business I'm also the
treasurer of a non-profit organization
this is my first experience in what I'll
call Managed living
I asked a bunch of questions at my first
annual meeting of the of the board in
and that put me on a certain trajectory
let's say I will say uh thank you to
representative almi and uh I'd say
overall the the new 356b Financial
disclosure language she's proposing or
is being proposed here could be quite
beneficial in supporting a single unit
owner or small group of unit owners who
are struggling to gain access to
financial information in their Condo
Association
uh the the first thing I would point out
is if you look at the language in 37 E2
it starts out quite optimistically uh
saying each unit owner shall have access
to all financial information however you
take you continue to read the sentence
and it's really specific to contracts
which are debatable I suppose I mean we
have a contract with the bank does that
mean I can get bank statements it
doesn't specifically stay I can get bank
statements why shouldn't I be able to
get bank statements it's my money in the
bank account
uh mortgages loans in terms of loans
um we don't have any of those but great
that that's good outstanding debts and
balances on all accounts held by the
Association well if you take this
literally like my uh my board of
directors and property managers uh have
uh that that would require them to give
me two numbers one for uh our operating
account and one for our Reserve account
that's all we we we we would get from
this any records uh supporting expenses
that one might want to uh take a look at
and which my board has has always said
the door is open in Campton New
Hampshire just come on down you can look
at everything and then as soon as I said
I'm coming they said not so fast and
then they broke their own rules and said
well I'll just copy you some stuff and
then I get an incomplete and incorrect
copy of whatever and this has been going
on and going on and going on that's just
the beginning of the process we don't
have time here to go into all the
details of it but I would say as um as
both a condominium owner and the owner
of a business because these are
businesses I I would say that unit
owners should uh should have more
explicit access through this language to
the books and records of of an associate
of their Association
even after I declared I was going to
audit my Association in accordance with
our bylaws my board reference 37 E2 and
stated they're not required to provide
access to the association books the
general ledger or tax returns it's
absolutely impossible to do a basic
financial statement review without
access to the general ledger it was
denied me
that was phase one now we're on phase
I think if I if I'm looking at 2A uh 37
e 2A I I think if I were to prioritize
some of that because it was mentioned
that there's a there's a there's a whole
bunch of stuff in there
um I would prioritize bank statements
um I I would say that from a general
awareness budget tracking and management
point of view bank statements are
probably the best single resource
available to unit owners especially unit
owners that are not part of the board
um I I was told our bank statements
would be available in person at the
property manager's office like I
mentioned uh and and and and that's fine
except the the property manager's office
is open on weekdays they're you know
from from nine to 4 30 or whatever I
live in Dover Massachusetts
generally it's a weekend warrior thing
you know you go up to the place and
you're using it on the weekend it's it's
not that easy to uh to get there
um I took I took a closer look at that
because it wasn't practical for me so I
did the homework I spoke with the Bank
of New Hampshire that's where we do our
banking uh and I also spoke with other
um other associations with regards to
how to make uh you know just access the
bank statements a little bit easier uh
and found that uh
um there's easy ways to satisfy banking
privacy laws and it's easy to truncate
and or eliminate account numbers for
security purposes either formally
through the bank by having a program
through them to do a quote-unquote unit
on a ready bank statement or um uh or by
simply getting out of Sharpie
um I offered a bunch of different Opera
options to my uh to my board they were
they were all uh all denied uh so you
know if I want a timely access to my
bank statements I've got to go you know
from Dover to Camden during the weekday
hours 12 times a year to get those
um
I would say in closing with regards to
the bank statements that you know in
this day and age when most banking is
done via electronic means and including
banking at our association it would seem
reasonable to add language uh that
appropriately crafted bank statements I
mean you got to be respectful of privacy
laws Etc uh be made available uh to unit
owners
with regards to Association uh Financial
audits uh I would say that obtaining
Financial transparency from an
entrenched HOA or condo association
board can be extremely difficult the
loan unit owner a group of unit owners
May encounter significant obstacles in
gaining access to financial information
I was quite pleased to find a unit owner
audit provision uh in in my bylaws as
representative Al May mentioned although
I continue to deal with significant
difficulties costs and stress if it was
not for that bylaw I would have been
dead in the water I wouldn't be maybe
not here today I I would say that adding
language that that allows unit owners
the opportunity to conduct their own
audits levels the playing field the
board can always do their audit but the
unit owner can't necessarily do theirs
um with that said uh uh and as the
language in 2B
points out
um
uses the word obtaining an independent
review I I would say now having gone
through what I've gone through that true
Independence uh and avoidance of
conflicts of interest or something uh to
be uh considered uh in in this in this
regard my Treasurer at one point after
he discovered and seemed like the whole
board discovered for the first time that
we hadn't been audited in 30 years uh
the property manager knew that very well
and quickly pointed out six reasons why
we don't need an audit
um uh he he decided a few months later
to go down to Campton and take a look at
the books and records and report it back
at a subsequent board meeting that
everything was fine
and I applauded that I'm like this is
great that's I'm just I'm just trying to
you know get some uh more transparency
and visibility into the process and the
numbers uh so I asked them afterwards
you know could I could we speak a little
bit about you know what you did what
your scope was you know just get some
idea of what you did and the answer was
one word
no
no I think the bylaws actually requires
them you know if he's going to go down
there and spend money and the PM's going
to spend money that he was you know he
owed us something uh but you know we
didn't get it so
um you know I so I would suggest that
any language
um uh with regards to audits provide for
Independence certainly you can have an
outside uh accountant uh you know
conduct an audit
um often there's relationships with with
those accountants already and there's
also easily a hundred different ways to
do audits
um you know having a board of directors
with perhaps inputs from the property
manager decide on the type of audit and
then managing the process delivering the
the results is a clear conflict of
interest in my mind both my board and P
and property manager have been trying to
dictate my audit efforts since day one
um uncovering fraud and embezzlement
well first of all fraud and embezzlement
is is real in this space it happens
Stone management being the most recent
example down in Waterville Valley
forensic accounting and a forensic
examination of the books is totally
different approach totally different
skill set uh versus doing just a
financial statement on it both have
tremendous value if the unit owners
could be involved in that and there
could be uh you know just other uh you
know inputs
um I think there's value in that you
know non-board members should have the
opportunity to be involved in any audit
process I would go further and say and
this is this is not in the language uh
as presented offering the option for
associations to assemble an audit
Committee of non-board unit owners makes
sense and removes that obvious conflict
uh of boards auditing themselves I don't
think that should require a vote I think
it should just be there and and they can
do it if they want or or not certainly
you know any budget uh allocated for um
for auditing purposes needs to be voted
on
um I do have a copy of
uh more uh that I put together that I
could uh provide uh in terms of the my
remarks but that that was all I uh
that's all I had great
thank you uh we do have a question
representative Burroughs
yeah thank you for taking the question
this is a quick one
I'll wait till you come back
thanks a lot okay I can talk while
you're welcome back
um my question is simple do you have any
insight as to why you're being
stonewalled by your Association on this
I'm just just curious why
why they're doing this um
at first I thought they just didn't like
me
um and I don't think they do
um so the question was is that all it is
but now two years or actually over two
years later I
it and it's just conjecture
I think there's something going on there
uh you know because I'm asking specific
questions and we're kind of beyond the
we don't like them I mean we don't like
them but they're going to Extraordinary
Measures spending a lot of money on
their attorneys is what their attorneys
are involved and uh and not only that
but but now we see with the upcoming
uh annual meeting
the board has has said what we're going
to try to do now since this has been so
contentious and confusing to them uh
that we're going to get rid of this unit
owner audit provision and we're going to
put that up for vote at the annual
meeting in three or four weeks so and
this is the this concludes perhaps a
half a dozen different rule changes
where it started what is come to Campton
the door is open nope not so fast we'll
give you copies back and forth on the
copies oh okay now you can do an audit
Bob you need a CPA and this is how it's
going to work okay let's do that we show
up representative almi mentioned got 30
minutes maybe 25 uh you know in in the
building not enough time my accountant
is frantically just trying to copy stuff
and and now we're to the point where
we're going to shut this down we're
going to get the vote we're going to
shut it down
so I you know I don't know is there
embezzlement going on here I I don't
know I'm just trying to do an audit I'm
just trying to let the facts
I'm just trying to follow the facts but
I can't even I can't even so I I
couldn't get the first one done the
financial statement audit and now we're
basically doing more of a fraud
examination and they can't even get
started
thank you for that and just for the
record my neighbors don't like me either
so I wouldn't worry about that
I'm sorry I wouldn't worry about work my
neighbors don't like me either so don't
worry about it if I was worried about
that okay well representative people
don't worry about that and they're and
that's why there's just one of me here
thank you Mr chairman uh maybe I should
address this to representative elmy but
I don't see any teeth in here I mean I
don't know much about these things but I
see nothing in here that would prevent
your your folks from just saying no
again is there a way to put some teeth
into yeah you have to look at the whole
statute
you're only looking at a little piece of
the statue you have to look at all three
502 356.
all right so thank you um okay I would
just say uh you know with regards to
electronic bank statements that that
that language is not in there uh and
adding a non-board uh member audit
great thank you very much thank you
um okay now well it's been timed uh who
is in opposition to the Bell
they're like Gary you're like yes and
you're like it's parts of it and you
don't like some of it
thank you Mr chairman will infantine
Hillsboro
um
16. I am in favor of the bill I have
concerns with some of the wording I've
been on a number of boards as I said uh
over the years and transparency with
finances is always Paramount and it
should be okay there's no reason in
today's technology I'm on two boards
right now A homeowners association and a
Condo Association every month I got a
list I got the bank statements I got a
list of every bill is paid we have to
get copies of the checks it's pretty
simple with today's technology to
provide that as a board member every
month to review the the information and
then to give it to anyone who wants to
see it via email whatever so I have no
problem with
most bylaws I've seen allow
for individuals to be able to go at a
certain place at a certain time that's
scheduled to go look at the information
um so yeah you're paying the bill you
should be able to see where the money's
going to the problem I have is is in
section
um B in the CPA world there's a
difference between a compilation to
review and an audit it's all
verification of a certain amount it's
it's all a level of verification
compilation is the simplest it looks
pre-verification an average comp
compilation would be twenty five to
three thousand dollars a review
statement does a little more
um uh independent review they send uh
they're going to check bank statements
they're going to send out a certain
amount of letters to all the receivables
and payables to make sure and get a get
the response back that they're accurate
and an audit full-blown audit you know
review review could be five to seven
thousand an audit could be ten thousand
dollars so while I respect
representative almi for having as she
said a purposely vague uh comments in uh
or wording in lines nine and ten
some words were mixed around if you're
going to have an independent review be
careful when you use the word review
because what it possibly means are you
talking about a CPA review
which is going to cost five or seven
thousand dollars a year that's okay for
100 unit Association but not for a 10
unit Association
I said a significant expense
um
it's also difficult to get a CPA or
anyone to do something every three years
so you're going to say I did it this
year I'm not going to wait three years
because I don't know what happened in
between so I got to go back and look at
everything else in between there to make
sure that my third year audit is going
to be consistent with follow-through
with what I did in the audit three years
ago
this independent review what does that
mean a guy who in your neighbor who does
an HR H R Block thing for everybody does
their taxes at the end of the year or is
it a CPA
is it someone within the association is
that someone not
uh the previous uh the gentleman
testified didn't think that it was okay
to have someone within the association
do it they didn't think they were
I a step away from it
so I think the warning just needs to be
clarified there because if you're asking
everyone to do an independent review or
have a CPA do it it's as significant
expense I'd rather have that say may
obtain because some associations do I've
gone to Association meetings where we
had had a police officer there in case
things got out of hand other
associations everybody looks the numbers
everyone's happy it all varies
okay so everyone should have the right
to see information make a schedule make
an appointment go see it get all the
information everything should be
transparent
how you do it in B is very important
because it could be very costly so I
would hope that that could be
um tightened up a bit Mr chairman thank
you
okay thank you uh
yes
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um on lot
on line 11 it states any owner at their
own expense
May demand a more detailed audit
so it's up to the owner it seems to pay
for the audit he's looking at the first
sentence look at nine and ten
the first sentence says they have to do
an independent review if they do a bare
basis compilation and that's not
acceptable to the person that wants more
and they want to pay a CPA to do an
audit and pay the extra five or seven
thousand dollars to do so
okay knock yourself out but nine and ten
I think the lines nine and ten need to
to the kind of Association
okay thank you Mr thank you very much
who wrote support and oppose but only
one to two minutes so you're gonna be
brief right uh I am yes thank you
um by the way just uh to make sure
records are straight uh did I invert the
number at all on that card I don't know
if I wrote the right number 2 2 39 you
got it right okay thank you uh okay so
for the record once again my name is
Gary Daddario I'm an attorney and a
partner with Marcus Erico Ameren Brooks
uh we focus our practice on community uh
law and condominium law so you know this
is what we do this is what I do on a
professional basis day in and day out I
am certainly not here to say that I have
any issue with transparency or with
associations financials being accurate
or with there being mechanisms for them
to be accurate so really I only have two
thoughts for you to consider
one is in I believe it's 2C where there
is reference to individual accounts and
that the individual account sort of
becomes part of the publicly available
information if there is a lien against
that unit owner I would caution that
that may not be enough from the
standpoint of the federal fair debt
collection practices act that act
prohibits the release of information
about an account to third parties and as
of right now it is uncertain whether or
not they even consider the mortgage
holder Who provided that two hundred
thousand dollars for the unit to be
purchased to be a third party so I have
to believe that they would consider all
of the other unit owners and whoever
they might share that information with
to be third parties and so while the
lien itself that exists at the registry
is a public record and would show that
that unit owner owes a particular dollar
amount at least at a certain time
their account information would be a
different story their account
information might show more of a balance
it might show partial payments or or
payments or you know a checkered payment
history
it could have any number of of pieces of
information in an individual unit or
account that if shared would expose the
association to that liability for
sharing that information with a third
party
so I think there might need to be some
tweaking there so that associations are
not uh required by New Hampshire law to
give up information that might otherwise
violate the applicable federal statute
um just something to to consider I'm
sure it can be worked around
um but again something to consider my
second thought it relates back to the
bill that we just got finished talking
about
and my thought is this I would ask you
to to give serious consideration to
whether or not you legislatively impose
on associations additional
administrative expenses in their
operations if they are going to continue
to be unable to end delinquency cases
even when unit owners haven't paid them
for one to two years
because whether we're talking about
hundreds of dollars for a simple review
or thousands of dollars for more complex
review if an association is suffering
with long-term delinquents and if years
are ticking by with balances growing and
condo fees not coming in and if they
don't have an ability to do something
like a foreclosure to end those cases to
get paying owners in those units then I
I just don't think it makes sense some
of them as I mentioned in my prior
testimony when you're having trouble
making ends meet now they're operating
at a deficit so I I think we should be
careful uh in telling associations that
by law you're going to have to incur
additional expenses
and that's all I I have on this
generally speaking again no problem with
financial transparency just I think a
couple of things that need to be
considered
great um so when we do our subcommittee
you might want to come in with
texts that you think is probably more
appropriate sure
all right seeing no questions thank you
very much thank you
okay having no more cards we'll close
the public hearing on 239 and and the
blue sheet did we get the blue sheet for
nope
okay well I'm not going to worry about
it at this moment so we'll just open go
ahead because we're really late now
representative magnitude you're going to
testify
I don't have the
Prime sponsors card
representative Davis here
good morning and I apologize for our
lateness thank you Mr chair and thank
you members of the committee
um I want to start by offering you two
apologies and one is that on the copy of
the bill that you have before you at
least I believe that's true the
co-sponsors are not listed and they are
lafa mangaputi and Eric Gallagher
uh and my second apology is that I
intend to um
to work up a slight Amendment to the
bill which I will talk about
um in in just a few minutes so thank you
very much
um this is a bill that seeks to
um provide some protections for
homeowners associations which come in
all shapes sizes and colors in this
state
from the purchase by a single corporate
entity or one individual of all the
majority of the units in the development
uh these homeowners associations do not
enjoy the protection of any New
Hampshire statutes
as do condominium associations
homeowners associations are most for the
most part organized under the voluntary
associations chapter of New Hampshire
law
section 292.
and uh and so this seeks to prevent
undo expenditures that would fall to a
municipality should a majority owner
purchase the majority of homes or all of
the homes in a homeowners association
and therefore the municipality that
approved the homeowners association
development in the first place would be
stuck with the costs of infrastructure
of maintaining that Community which
would normally devolve upon the
homeowners
so that's what this bill attempts to do
and it is an amendment to the voluntary
associations chapter under which many
homeowners associations in this state
and other states are formed
and the amendment that I mentioned a
little earlier would be under in line
seven
uh under Roman numeral two and it would
say no homeowners association
constituted under this chapter and
approved by a planning board shall be
dissolved
etc etc
prior to a hearing under RSA 676 colon 2
before that planning board so in other
words I'm I'm taking out the possibility
that a homeowners association that does
not have any planning Board review and
approval would be would enjoy the same
protection
uh that that this would under under this
proposed bill
and that is the sum total of it I thank
you for listening and I'd be happy to
so go for me because I was maybe a pain
enough attention what exactly is the
problem do we have a historic event that
occurred what can you walk me through
something that that occurred that was so
problematic that we need to pass this
legislation
we have a worry not not a historic event
but a worry about a future event
uh we have investors coming into our
homeowners association on a regular
basis
asking residents what's it going to take
to get you to move
I have a check right here how big do you
need the check to be
and these are usually corporations
Hospitality corporations that would like
to purchase all or a majority of the
homes in the HOA and turn them into
so not a historic event but worry about
okay
see none thank you very much
thank you
okay uh Margaret burns from
New Hampshire Municipal Association I
assume
is uh opposed to the bill I'm good
morning uh members of the committee my
name is Margaret Burns I'm the executive
director of the New Hampshire Municipal
Association
um we are opposed to the bill but only
with respect to paragraph two or section
two which deals with the required
planning the required hearing before a
planning board in the event of a
dissolution of a homeowners association
I have spoken to Representatives Davis
before the hearing about the amendment
that she spoke to the committee about
just a moment ago and I think it would
fix our concerns with the bill as
written Our concern right now is that a
hearing would be required before a
planning board even in a certain
situation where the HOA wasn't a
condition of approval on the subdivision
or the site plan for that particular
development and we don't want to create
a situation where planning boards are
put into a private home owner type
situation where they really don't have
regulatory Authority but in some
instances when site plans or
subdivisions are approved the planning
board will actually make it a condition
of approval that a homeowners
association be formed for the specific
reason of taking care of Maintenance or
preserving conservation land or other
easements because it's a privately owned
development as opposed to one that is
creating public roads or other public
infrastructure that the town would
normally have the responsibility for so
we completely understand what it's
seeking to address but with the
amendment that Representatives Davis
described it would probably take care of
the concern we have about mandating a
planning board hearing in all
circumstances of an HOA dissolution so
that is all I have for Testimony I won't
prolong my testimony but I am happy to
take any questions that the committee
has
foreign
okay
um normally the I would think
the municipal Association wouldn't take
an opinion on a bill that's
uh in the in the words of uh
representative Kirk it used to be
prophylactic we were trying to solve a
problem before it occurs uh so and and
obviously increasing responsibilities
now the town we get involved in it so
are you not concerned that that this is
a preventative medicine rather than
addressing a problem that really
occurred again we support the intent of
the bill and the issue it's trying to
fix the reason that we have opposition
is that it mandates a planning board
hearing in all circumstances even where
the planning board has not exercised its
local authority to require that HOA to
be formed in the first place so you are
a hundred percent correct normally we
would not take a position on a bill
that's seeking to actually
get ahead of a potential issue down the
road the concern is that planning boards
will be required to hold a hearing even
where they have no regulatory Authority
with respect to the the HOA dissolution
which could create a lot of confusion
both for planning boards as well as for
homeowners in the HOA so the amendment
described I think would ameliorate that
issue got it
any other questions I think we've seen
done thank you very much thank you
okay representative valmie wants to
reps have Susan Almay on Grafton 17 on
you asked about his historical incident
we have already had one and we came
before this committee to provide a
solution which I I thought was
completely inadequate and I like this
one better but it was when
somewhere in the Eastern Lakes Region I
believe there was a group of people that
were friends in Massachusetts that put
together a homeowners association on and
on a lake and they built their nice
homes next to it and on they were
planning on selling other Lots in order
to get them to uh
on to pay back some of their expenses
and they were not getting anybody buying
them because the market was not good at
that point and they um
they dissolved the homeowners
association by themselves
and uh
10 years later they decided to start
trying to sell a lots again the market
was better people moved in there was an
a voluntary agreement made that
everybody would pay into the common pot
to pay for snow plowing and things like
that
and ten years after that the original
board which was still running the place
decided that we can get some of our
money back from those earlier years and
they made it they they refiled as the
homeowners association
and they then sent a bill to the people
the new people telling them that they
owed what they had already paid
they owed that again as back
10 years of homeowner association dues
when they hadn't been a homeowners
association
on and that went through the court
system I don't think it went to the
Supreme Court eventually but the
superior court
and I can't quite remember what the
resolution was but it wasn't totally
satisfactory for those uh 10 other lots
and on what we did and what you passed
was to say that the Secretary of State's
office which they had filed with as a
voluntary corporation on was
I don't think it was quite those words
but uh they they had filed with on had
to hold a hearing
before
such a institution could be dissolved or
reconstituted as the same one
and that is in law now but a most places
wouldn't know about it and B on The
Association members that were being
find essentially for previous years were
wouldn't wouldn't know about it
so
yeah I only thought you could do a
three-year look back yeah so so that
that is
a historical incident and I'm pretty
sure there have been some others in home
with homeowner associations fair enough
but without credit well thank you for
contributing that
okay uh I think having no more cards but
we will close I will close the public
hearing as soon as I have the blue sheet
knowing assuming there's not much on
there uh for the members of the
committee
um I have scheduled for next week I
don't know if it's been sent out yet
um it has been okay
um and so what it turns out is that um
the following week uh in my in our uh if
it turns out the fishing game only has
one bill and uh so that means their
committee room and time is actually open
on a Tuesday
so um uh as I've said to you all before
I uh the idea of having a Friday uh day
for the Commerce is was anathema for me
and so
um pay attention uh now to that calendar
that Tuesdays potentially will be a day
where we'll have hearings
but not next week because
um they're sharing with three committees
for that committee room but
but so anyways going forward
um so uh and more importantly
um we have six bills that um have an
early departure date and which means
they're going to a second committee
um and so I've got those all scheduled
for next week the hearings and then we
would be doing the subcommittee's work
on those bills uh the following week
February I think it's February 1st
Wednesday the first we'll need to get
the sub committee work we have to vote
on them by the 16th so I usually like to
schedule a couple of subcommittees so we
have plenty of opportunity to work on
those bills and obviously
um yes
the marijuana bills are one of them is a
is an early departure bill so we we need
to really delve into it it's 34 pages
long and um I haven't
gotten my red pen out yet but I'm I'm
hoping that we will not try to try to
sort through a 34 page Bill uh in two
weeks
um so we'll see how that goes but anyway
just want to give you all a heads up on
that
otherwise we're adjourned and I'll see
you all back in an hour
foreign
open up the public hearing on 383 and
hear from representative Rockford
laughs
yeah
good afternoon good afternoon
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee uh my name is David rochefer
I'm a representative from Littleton I
represent Grafton one I'm a second
generation pharmacist and until last
February I was a pharmacy owner I
currently work part-time as a uh in a
for a pharmacy management serve company
doing uh the part-time work around the
country but the bill I'm about to
present HB 383 this is not an
earth-shattering bill
um I I want to save you from from
widespread PBM reform today
uh it's not a New Concept in fact the
New Hampshire legislature has recognized
this issue that's presented in HB 383 as
a relevant issue and the overall major
tenets of 383 are already found in RSA
402n I see HB 383 is more of a
modernization of current law and it just
closes some loopholes to make the
current law work a little bit more
efficiently and make it more work as
intended when it was first passed
um I'm going to talk about it here at a
high level uh and and and but I do have
some current Pharmacy owners here with
me to get into some specifics to answer
some of the specifics and how it
functions uh in in real life if you will
um who will come come up after me
uh however before I get going I do want
to Define some terms that will be used
for today I think it's important I
understand that these terms are very
specific to our industry and uh um and I
think it might be helpful to understand
as we as we move along so the first term
I want to Define is a pharmacy benefit
manager uh you'll also hear this term
defined as a PBM three-letter term pbms
are middlemen companies uh that
insurance companies hire to carry out
their drug benefit the pbms in turn not
the insurance companies contract with
the pharmacies to assemble a pharmacy
Network
pbms determine which pharmacies will be
included in a prescription drug plans
Network and how much said pharmacies
will be paid for their services and I
think it's important to note that three
pbms three three individual pbms control
80 percent of the drug benefit
transactions in the United States and
all of them own their own pharmacies
the other term that I want to discuss is
Mac pricing Mac
so in an effort to control costs pbms
frequently utilize a pricing concept
called Mac or maximum allowable cost the
Mac is the maximum amount that a
pharmacy benefit manager will reimburse
a pharmacy for the cost of a drug this
is a contracted agreement that the
pharmacy will take whatever the PBM has
decided to pay them for a particular
drug and because drug prices fluctuate
frequently the Mac reimbursement
oftentimes doesn't keep up with the drug
prices especially in the volatile drug
price markets we've seen lately so
the concept is important to understand
especially as consumers you know being
that Mac is a contracted agreement
between a pharmacy and a PBM it's not
like going into the The Market Basket
and seeing a dozen eggs and saying I'm
only going to pay two dollars for this
dozen of eggs when they're selling for
seven they're contractually obligated to
take whatever price that the PBM is
telling them to pay so it's a contracted
agreement and understanding that these
prices are fluctuating every day the
other concept that we've heard a lot
about in the news that I just want to
write remind folks here today about is
transparency and as we talk about
transparency and Drug pricing there
appears to be room for improvement in
the manner in which premiums communicate
Mac pricing and the sources of the
products to which Mac pricing has been
applied unclear and opaque methodology
is a relic of the past and we all
understand that a hidden Market is not a
free market
so I mentioned previously that the
concept in HB 383 is not the first time
the legislature has had Mac pricing in
front of it in fact we have statutes on
the books dealing with this issue so
this bill HB 383 is not a radical new
legislation in fact SB 226 of 2019
established that if a PBM had a maximum
allowable cost or a Mac pricing on a
given drug that was below the available
acquisition cost for a pharmacy the PBM
had to provide the pharmacy with a
source where the drug could be obtained
at or below the Mac price
so that means if a pharmacy submits a
claim for a particular drug amoxicillin
and the reimbursed claim comes at below
the drug price that's actually costs and
that Mac price is below the actual
acquisition cost that PBM has to supply
a source to where that Pharmacy can buy
that drug at that lower price
that's in law already
this bill closes a loophole HB 383 in
front of you closes a loophole in the
law and it states that the PBM must
provide the pharmacy where the what
wholesaler doing business in New
Hampshire
where that drug is available at or below
that Mac price so it kind of finishes
the sentence of what we have in statute
already
this bill also requires that the PBM
notify all pharmacies in the network
when it finds that a Mac price is below
acquisition costs and allows them to
rebuild at the more appropriate
reimbursement rate
current practice is that a PBM provides
a portal that a pharmacy must log into
but given the technological advances
employed in modern Pharmacy this
information can be transmitted and
disseminated instantly pbms can actually
calculate prescription deductibles in
real time they can do because they can
do this and because that technology is
available they certainly can communicate
out to pharmacies when and where these
these prices are available
again this is not radical reform
legislation I'm not here to prevent to
provide you or present to you some type
of groundbreaking
legislation that's uh that's gonna gonna
rock this world
um it just cleans up some areas that we
found in previous legislation that we
feel need improving
so I'm happy to answer some general
questions about this but like I said
I've got I've got pharmacists here that
have come out today that have taken time
off of their work to answer very
specific questions they're here to to
answer your questions and how this would
work functionally in their pharmacies
today so if you have some questions for
me I'd be happy to answer them otherwise
I'd be happy to turn this over to them
but yeah I don't have any other
cards do they do they I did I left some
up there for you
um
these are
I left them with mine I left a card and
I left there's I told them to leave
theirs up there too all right
okay so uh Glenn perald yes
oh someone had a question I'm sorry I
didn't see the hand uh yes thank you yes
representative
very briefly
will the proposed change have any effect
one way or the other on consumer costs
and if so what
so I think any time that you improve
transparency in pricing anytime that
there's an effort to to make the process
uh more visible whether it be to the
pharmacies that are participating in it
I think that there's always an
opportunity to improve cost you know the
concern that I have when
continuing on the process that there is
now when pharmacies are forced to sell
drugs at below costs uh or because again
this is a contracted agreement they're
just not going to carry the drugs and
they're not going to participate in
these programs and if you need a drug
and this is continually being what we
call macked at below cost the pharmacies
are not going to carry the drug so you
know it will affect it could affect cost
improving cost prices but it certainly
will affect access to care if this can
continues on it's my opinion
well it's funny to say that because I
was sitting there saying to myself
if they're going to tell you the PBM is
going to tell you where you can get it
at this low price
that means you didn't have it in stock
in the first place
absolutely well with these Mac prices
are generally applied to multi-source
generics so if you have amoxicillin for
instance which we you know use for sore
throats and antibiotic there might be 12
different companies that make
amoxicillin so my wholesaler might sell
six of them eight of them 10 of them but
if they're basing their Max Mac pricing
on that 11th or 12th product brand that
my wholesaler doesn't have or or or is
available that we don't know about we
want to know about that and so we can
bring that product in and and and and
sell it at that lower price and
therefore comply with the Mac pricing
right but you're you're you don't want
to sell it below cost I get that
um you have your wholesaler who you used
to using and then it turns out that
there's somebody out there that has it
at a lower price
and now we have a chicken in the egg how
you're you're saying that they need to
let you know the PM needs to know let
you know ahead of time we don't even
know whether what who you're getting it
from in the first place right
well in in
and I can let these guys can speak to
that a little bit clearer because
they're they're dealing with the
wholesalers on a on a daily basis and
their contract with them and they can
tell you how that functionality will
work
um
and I'm going to let them answer that
question right so just so you know what
where my thought was as soon as you had
said oh there could be a lower price my
first reaction is you but you're going
to have to tell the customer I I'm not
going to sell it to you I'm not going to
give it to you today because I don't
have it at the price point in which the
insurance companies PPM is going to
reimburse me Adam but if I have it in
stock
and I'll let these guys comment on that
we have to sell it at that price we have
the product in stock and it's on our
shelves and we transmit a claim for that
that that that that that
product right we have to sell it even if
it's below our costs so we have to sell
the contractually obligated to sell it
at a loss
okay well that's interesting all right
thank you
hi my name is Glenn peralt I'm a
pharmacist and also a pharmacy owner in
New London New Hampshire
um and I'm here obviously in support of
this bill
um
there are several instances that come up
weekly that Dave was trying to describe
where I have current stock on my
Pharmacy Shelf
and are being and being reimbursed below
what I pay for that drug on my shelf
I either submit a request for adjustment
or I have a
um
a party submit an adjustment on my
behalf and many many many times that
request is unsuccessful and if it is
successful I get a very very brief note
back from the PBM saying
um that the product is available cheaper
in the marketplace
that's the end of it
I have no idea where to find it I have
no idea if it's even a U.S supplier
um like uh Mr Rochford was saying
representative roach was saying if that
product is on my shelf I am
contractually obligated to sell that to
fill that prescription and sell that
product even if it's at a loss
um
the
um Contracting
um process that we undergo with the pbms
is not a negotiated process it is a take
it or leave it you may have access to
our patients
if you accept this rate
um I can speak
personally right now for calendar year
our Pharmacy is
um unable to service around 800 patients
because of contracts that were offered
to my Pharmacy
um seven percent below my acquisition
cost
um
I have no recourse I have to find a home
for my 800 patients
um what this bill will do is it will put
the onus some onus back on the PBM to
identify a supplier in the state of New
Hampshire that I can purchase
medications for to fulfill my
and I'm happy to entertain any any
questions
well that's pretty straightforward
so and I I I have an open invitation to
any representative who wants to come up
in the pharmacy and just see what we do
every day and and uh see what I'm trying
to explain in action
so they the pbms right now have no
particular obligation to let you know
who they want you to who to have as a
wholesaler that's correct
um and and there's even some
um Mac responses that we get back where
the the product in question is not the
product that I am requesting a Mac
adjustment on uh for example
um there may be a a a two ounce tube of
cream
that says no our Mac is fine order this
particular
um every drug has what's called an NDC
number a National Drug code
they provide me an NDC number and and
what I see time and time again
is an NDC number for a smaller pack size
well of course that pack size is going
to be below your Mac for the 60 gram
pack size this is just some of the real
world situations that we're dealing with
in the pharmacy and what we're hoping
that this bill will address and and
clean up
good now we have questions
Representatives
I know that a pharmacy has a limited
size and shelf area and uh
expiration dates on drugs and things
like that what would you say the
percentage of drugs
are that of what you have in your area
of what people want are actually
available that
you would not necessarily have to go out
and just say all right I'll get it back
in two days
um so I would say that we probably fill
between 95 and 99 of all the
prescriptions that walk through the door
um very very rarely do we have to make a
special order
um for an item with our Pharmacy is a
very very busy Pharmacy we fill upwards
of of
um 10 000 prescriptions a month and so
we typically have a fairly
substantial inventory
so you you could be hit with this Mac
limitation if you will on across a lot
of drugs so my my Mac requests
um in my Pharmacy
generally there is about a dozen to a
dozen and a half Mac adjustment requests
per week
um and I would say out of that dozen and
a half I would say less than one are
adjusted I would say with out of out of
a hundred Mac requests we probably have
about two
that actual
um they're actually adjusted
and the difficult part about
The Adjustment and allowing us to go
back and rebuild the claim is
this time of year we have several people
who are meeting deductibles and so we
transmit the prescription off and the
patient's not paying a copay they're
paying the full adjusted price of that
prescription and so now I go back two
three weeks later rerun the claim and it
tells me that I oh I shouldn't charge
the patient you know 150 I should have
charged the patient a hundred and
seventy dollars well
I'm not going to call the patient I'm
saying oh by the way you underpaid by 20
bucks you got to come back
it's very difficult situation that we're
put in
Representative Vincent
thank you Mr chairman and thanks a lot
for taking my question
um this pbm's company is a negotiated
you may have said but is it negotiated
by the insurance company
do they hire these people yeah it's yes
a PBM um so an insurance company say
Anthem Blue Cross does not handle
prescription claims at all they say they
they will hire and I believe in anthem's
case they hire a company called Express
Scripts and they said you handle our
insurance you you do all prescriptions
run it the way you want to run it the
pbn will come back and say okay you want
to allow 90-day 90-day prescriptions at
retail do you want to have a mandatory
mail order do you they set up all the
rules in the and the insurance company
says yes and no and yes and no
um and that
is offered now after all those questions
are answered the PBM will take that
contract and we'll present that to the
pharmacy whether it's an independent
like me or whether it's a chain store
they will say this is how that plan
works this is your reimbursement
you can either
choose to service these people
or not
one quick follow-up
for the question and
um so how long is this issue a problem
been exists how long has this been going
on
so I have been a pharmacist in the state
of New Hampshire since April 14th of
1984.
and it's been a challenge since then
not to this degree
not not until recently over the last
four or five years have we been seeing
the number of underwater claims
at the rate it is now
and it's to the severity it is now
um I my my
last contracts that I had to refuse
um
were offered at seven percent below
what I could buy the drugs for and
speaking to some of my colleagues and
asking them what some of their buying
contracts are it's it's across the state
it's not just me and I have a big
Pharmacy I mean I have a very busy
Pharmacy we have great buying power
thank you thank you Mr chairman
representative Terry
thank you uh so Mike my question hello
hi oh hi thanks hi yes you can't tell
the players without a scorecard
uh right here so I want to make sure
that um my question is going to be
predicated upon my my understanding in
an accurate understanding so if it's not
please
you you uh
you you charge twenty five dollars for
you pay 25 for a particular drug
all right and the pharmacy benefit
manager comes back and says uh we're
only going to give you 15.
all right got it correct you you asked
them who's the wholesaler correct and
they want and they won't tell you
they don't tell you
have you asked them why they will not
have you ever asked them why will you
not tell me how you came up with fifteen
dollars who's the wholesaler and and if
and if that's the case that they will
not tell you then do you have any
confidence that they're telling you the
truth if they won't tell you that's
correct we we don't
um that these are just maybe made up
prices well we we that's right we we
don't know and and and to this point
um
we don't know how to proceed and
challenge that we know that the
insurance commission is responsible for
enforcing the the statutes but we don't
know the Avenue in which to pursue and
who to pursue at the insurance
commission we constantly run into
roadblocks with the insurance commission
trying to enforce
okay thank you thanks so I guess we want
to hear from the PCMS
bcmas Curtis you guys yeah we we try to
go back and forth
so you're going to hear their story and
then you'll be able to come to respond
to what they say
it's okay I assume the two of you are
yes yeah thank you good afternoon uh Mr
chair members of the committee my name
is Curtis Barry I'm here on behalf of
the pharmaceutical Care Management
Association otherwise known as pcma
which is the national trade Association
for the PBM industry we have several
members that are active here in New
Hampshire with me is Sam hollimeyer from
pcma and before I turn it over to Samba
for the primary testimony
um I wanted to point out I've left a
packet for each one of you and wanted to
walk through that real briefly the first
page would look like this sort of a
chart that describes
the supply chain and the reimbursement
chain for pharmaceuticals it is fairly
complicated and it's not like other
medical suppliers
so you start with the drug makers
obviously the physical drugs that the
pharmacists are talking about then
transfer to a wholesaler which then
sells to the pharmacy
on the other side on the right hand
column you have a PBM which can be
contracted with an insurance carrier
some carriers do the PBM Services
in-house PBM can also contract with a a
self-insured large employer
um and the patient is a member uh
through their health benefit with their
employer
um so their the pharmacy benefit manager
does exactly that it manages the
pharmacy benefit for either the employer
or the the insurance company importantly
on this chart I want to point out that
the wholesalers have no direct
connections to the pbms
they buy their drugs from the
manufacturer and sell to the pharmacy
we cannot any PBM cannot dictate from
whom a pharmacy purchases drugs and
cannot get involved in in those
negotiations
in the negotiations for the purchase
those contracts if you look at the
second page typically are handled by
what's known as a psao Sam we'll get
into that a little bit more but the
psaos of Pharmacy Services
Administration organization that serves
in part to negotiate contracts between
pbms and pharmacies also to negotiate I
understand between the wholesaler and
the pharmacy itself so if somebody knows
the information that they're looking for
the wholesalers know what their prices
are maybe we should be talking to them
about their pricing they're the ones
that are we heard testimony that are
causing the fluctuation of the price
that the pharmacy pays or maybe the psao
who was involved in negotiating those uh
those contracts
uh the next page I've provided for you
the the con the full
um text of the current statute that was
referred to previously uh and based upon
a recent comment I want to point out
right at the very beginning uh Roman 1
small a all contracts between a carrier
or a pharmacy benefit manager and a
contract of Pharmacy shall include the
source is used by the pharmacy benefit
manager to calculate the drug product
reimbursement paid for cover drugs under
the pharmacy Health Plan
so we're required to show them how the
Mac price was achieved in essence and
then there are other Provisions in here
uh related to what happens if the claim
is denied which also requires some
information
uh there's a copy of Sam's testimony
here uh and then a one-pager on Mac
pricing in general and one more point
I'd like to make for the committee's
information New Hampshire is what's
known as an any willing provider State
relative to Pharmacy that happened an
awful long time ago
um Donnelly delozo uh we won't tell the
story but in essence New Hampshire
statute for 30 or so years states that a
pharmacy must be let into the network if
the pharmacy is willing to uh adhere to
the terms and conditions that's offered
by the insurance carrier or the PBM in
other words the pbmo carrier cannot
cherry pick or just decide no we don't
want you in the network just because
every Pharmacy must be led into the
network if they're willing to adhere to
the terms and conditions so with that
I'd like
Sam turn it over to Sam for the
testimony thank you Curtis
good afternoon chairman hunt Vice
chairman and members of the committee my
name is Sam hollimeyer I Am director of
state affairs for pharmaceutical Care
Management Association pcma which is the
PBM National trade Association and I'm
here to oppose House Bill 383 today
before I get into the bill
um I did handouts as Curtis mentioned
some written testimony I do want to
highlight exactly what Mac is again it's
maximum allowable cost a maclist
specifies how much a PBM will reimburse
any given Pharmacy on a generic drug a
generic can be made by several different
manufacturers and sold to pharmacies at
different price points because of this
PBM set and regularly update the Mac the
Mac list by surveying Market data from
nationally recognized pricing reference
Services wholesalers as well as drug
manufacturers the purpose of a Mac list
is to encourage encourage a pharmacy to
purchase drugs to purchase generic drugs
at the lowest price that they possibly
can driving competition amongst
wholesalers and keeping costs down for
pay patients
pbms have no insight to the
relationships between pharmacies and
wholesalers so I'm going to end on that
now to get in the specifics of the bill
so section one sub B would require pbms
to notify the source a pharmacy can
purchase a drug app or below the Mac
price there was discussions earlier on
that the PBM would have to require to
notify a pharmacy where that Mac price
came from
but with this bill would not require
that a wholesale or sell it to that
pharmacy at that price I think that's
what a big point is missing here that
these pharmacies want to know where they
can get that price but there's no
guarantee that the wholesaler can sell
it to them at that price again those are
negotiated rates between a pharmacy a
psao and a wholesaler not the PBM the
PBM has no insight to that information
next is section two sub B there's a the
phrase actual cost is in here there's no
definition in New Hampshire statute and
we're we're pretty unsure of what that
might mean so we had a question on what
actual cost was again that's section two
sub B
um again section two sub B would require
pbms to notify notify all pharmacies of
immaculous change
um pbms have no way of knowing if a
pharmacy purchase a drug below or above
a Mac price unless they let us know so
we're unsure of how notifying them would
have worked for us and then finally
section three sub D would require that
pbm's Supply are Mac list to the
insurance department these Mac lists are
hundreds of pages long and they're
updated frequently so it's a huge burden
for the Department in our opinion and uh
we already applied we already supplied
in the pharmacies
so we would suggest a request that we
strike that from the bill thanks for the
opportunity to testify today and I'm
let me get this straight
you're going
to say content there's a Mac price and a
certain dollar amount from a certain
wholesaler
irregardless of whether that wholesaler
even sells into the state of New
Hampshire
the data that we receive I believe is
from the state of New Hampshire and just
markets in general in the area yes
so would there be volume discounts there
certainly are but we are not aware of
those volume discounts provided to
pharmacies
you are aware of a Mac price you have a
price they're reported to us yes and
that Mac price doesn't take into
consideration that this was only
supplied to a certain large employer
well I'm not like erisa that it wasn't
available even in the small group Market
that it was that price was a negotiated
price between a
big Corporation and that wholesaler
they've got that negotiated price you're
using that as the basis but that price
is not might not available for anybody
else but that Corporation
I I don't know that answer off the top
of my head I'd have to go back and look
chairman
do you follow where I'm going on this I
holy moly okay representative Denson
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question so let me get this
straight because I'm a little fogged in
the fog about this on January 1st I buy
I'm a I'm a pharmacist and I buy
something for ten dollars and on January
15th it comes in and it's changed by the
pbms
dealer it's five dollars
is there any time between the first and
the 15th where there's a notification
notification process to let them to let
the pharmacist know if it's going to go
down or not yes the pharmacies have
access to a portal where they can see a
Mac price reimbursement in real time so
these Mac lists are also provided to
pharmacies regularly but yes there is a
portable available for pharmacies to
view that price
thank you Mr chairman thank you okay
representative Sullivan
thank you yeah I'm just curious
following up on the representative
business question how often are these
portals updating like is this something
that's updating every day every week
every month every year currently in
statute we were pbms are required to
update it every 14 days
so I don't know I don't know the
business really at all but could a
Pharmacy by a certain stock of product
and it would maybe last two months or
are they just buying one week's worth of
time and so that's actually a relevant
amount of time I I can't answer that
I'm sorry yes representative gifts
thank you
can you tell us if you know if any other
states have requirements such as those
provided in this bill and if they do
if those requirements cause any problems
thank you representative for the
question could you be more specific is
it the whole bill in general or is there
a specific portion of the bill
I'm sorry I can't be more specific this
area is very unfamiliar to me and it's a
very complex situation
um and you're testifying against the
bill but nobody has mentioned how common
these types of requirements are and so
that's what I was asking and I was
hoping so you know this is interesting
how many states have that any willing
provider statute
because I remember when we had this
floor debate and I said to Donnelly I
said Donnelly
there could be PR the pharmacist could
be having to just because they want to
service the customer
they could have to pay more because they
don't have the volume that another a
different pharmacist might have and she
said the pharmacists were just want to
that was what the floor debate was
for any willing provider specifically
I'll get you that information I don't
know that but I think that's what it was
the debate around the any willing
provider issue
um sorry could I go back to my question
yes so what your question is is that any
other states other states have this
problem and the answer would be is how
many other states have the any willing
provider statute uh no I'm afraid not
um it's it's a transparency requirements
requirements proposed I understand that
we have the Annie willing provider
statute but this bill then goes to
transparency requirements as I
understand it
and what I'm asking is do other are
there other states that have these
transparency requirements and if there
are
do those requirements cause any problems
I don't have that information readily
readily available representative but I'd
be happy to look into it and follow up
with that information thank you
thank you so just so everybody
understands what does any willing
provider statue is about it was about
that theoretically if you want your
volume you want to get the best price
from your pharmacy from the farm for
your Pharmaceuticals the generally the
the insurance company is going to
exterior you to the mail order company
that I I would say that we won't see a
mail order company in here with this
complaint because they know exactly what
they're going to get reimbursed because
that's a negotiated price between the
PBM and that mail order company what
we're dealing with here is is we're
dealing with independent pharmacists
who are the customers going to them
because they don't want to get it in the
mail they want to deal with a local
person and the problem then is is that
the pbms do not have individual uh
contracted pricing they just have this
agreement that they will reimburse
okay
chairman uh if I understand this
correctly with the pbms you say you
update through the portal every 14 days
or so
so there's potentially
thousands of possible price changes is
that correct
I don't know off the top of my head how
often or how frequently individual ndcs
are updated but again it's all on
generic drugs I would think you you
would have the you know the experience
to answer that I would think I would
hope right again if I may I want to come
back to the relationship
that exists in this sort of the the
reimbursement Arena
um we the PBM has no control zero over
how much the wholesalers ask for their
drugs how often they increase those
prices
Etc and one of the uh Concepts behind
Mac pricing is not necessarily to
reimburse for actual cost because if we
were if PBM was required to do that
there would be no incentive for the
wholesaler to keep their costs down they
could raise prices to whatever price
they wanted and the PBM is then required
to pay those prices and at the end of
the day it's the premium payers then who
would face the increased cost for the
question being Claire yes thank you I
have a follow-up so
just for example on Amazon Amazon knows
all when I buy things and it says hey
this has been something you've bought
and here's a price change so in this
industry is there any type of data that
can provide the pharmacists the pharmacy
owners that okay this is the the data on
this particular drug that it's been
going down down down down so be aware is
there any type of you know notification
process
or data involved as to trending trending
data that show that can provide them
with a heads up in the future so like I
mentioned previously there is a portal
that pharmacies can take a look at to
see what the current MAC reimbursement
would be
as far as a trend going down like your
question is in that negotiated
contracted rate my response would be
that's between the the psao which was
mentioned previously and the PBM as well
as the pharmacy as well so they would
have to go back and renegotiate the con
that con contracted rate
if they wanted to update that price I I
hope I'm answering your question
correctly
so so you're not supposed to admit that
as far as again the Mac price reflects
what the current market trend is so if
the trend is going down or up the Mac
okay great thank you thank you Steve you
am I on yep my name is Steve cavadias I
am also a pharmacist and I am also a
pharmacy owner in Penacook
uh I find all these and questions very
intriguing
and I I do have my own response to all
of them but I I can't remember them all
but I would like to respond to your
question at the very beginning if this
was going to increase the cost
so if you look at the statute the
statute already says that they're
supposed to reimburse us at or above
cost
we're not asking for anything different
we're just asking for you to tell us
where we can get that so there's
basically three primary wholesalers just
like there are three primary pbms that
are all involved with supplying the PBM
owned pharmacies
that are that the pharmacies use for
secondaries
they also have their own pharmacies mail
order so so the concept of pbms not
knowing the price of a drug whoever
asked that
is beyond my comprehension
I I don't know how they know that and or
don't know that in addition to that with
the the the the way they come up with
the mac and they're they're checking all
these resources
well then why are they below cost and
and it doesn't really matter the statute
says it's above cost and we're just
asking for well where is that when they
say that it's cumbersome that that they
cannot provide us this detail daily on
hundreds of claims I get this person can
no longer get refills it has to go to
mail order this person can no longer get
this product it has to be that product I
get all sorts of messages not one
says Oh Let's help you find a place that
can keep you in business because
although I enjoy taking care of people I
also have to pay my staff
so
any other questions we can I tried to
you're fine Representative Vincent
thank you Mr chairman and I I don't want
so you says they changed these prices
every 14
but what happens if you have a big
demand for four months on ABC medication
and then you stock up on the first of a
month and then hold on and then
you got if you got 20 cases of a
medication but you have 10 left and then
they change the price
you're stuck with that pricing now you
lose correct correct
thank you well and I can take this even
further there is a PBM
that makes it an an auditable offense if
I buy a a product in bulk outside of the
30-day window of the claim
so now I'm restricted on negotiating for
a better price
oh one more quick follow-up Mr chairman
very fast so we've looked at it going
down has it ever gone the other way and
gone up I I can't I yes there are there
are success stories of Mac changes
uh I have noticed recently that I lose
Less on epinephrine injections or
epipens
thank you and some of these losses are
in the hundreds of dollars we're not
mm-hmm
knowing how small pharmacies work being
a primary care provider I wrote a lot of
prescriptions for the pharmacy where we
worked at our hrsa but I wrote a lot of
prescriptions for my homeless patients
for small pharmacies because the prices
were very often lower
my question to you is some of the things
that impacted us was that we didn't have
enough staff to be able to look up those
sites
we had a person that was working that
was able to do that for our Corporation
every day
um in the setting of a small Pharmacy
can you give me an idea of what the
impact would be labor-wise having to
look up all that data well just to give
you
um an answer to how we manage that and
maybe this will answer your question a
little bit
is that we use our psao which thank you
for telling me what the the abbreviation
meant because I didn't know
um to do uh research and to
um to challenge these Mac prices
and so I I call my psao yesterday and
asked them some just some silly numbers
on on what this looks like so from the
time of December 16th to January 16th
2926 appeals I believe
generally I asked them what is the
success rate and they say generally it's
around five percent but last year it was
seven percent
okay so when I look at the the
PBM that were on that list predominantly
it's it's it's one of the bigger ones
and when I look at the top
um
uh a successful appeals in this past
week it was only one PBM which of course
was a different one uh and and it's very
limited as as to the number
so yes there are people working on this
on our behalf am I able to fill out a
request based on a claim no it's hard
enough to do a prior authorization that
I'm sure everybody in this room is aware
of that you need something and of course
everybody has to jump through hoops
um so there are there are ways of
getting around this but I I cannot do it
you know we have so many requirements
and laws and regulations that we have to
follow
and we do it without issue whereas we
have a law here that's already in effect
and we have to beg to ask them to to to
please follow it and in the spirit of
all working together will tell us where
where we can get this from don't make me
go through the hundreds of of
wholesalers to figure out where I can
buy this and then restrict me afterwards
and in addition to that the new game
that we have playing is that they're
requiring specific
manufacturers for some generics that I I
can't even get or I can't get on
contract which violates a whole bunch of
other contracts that I'm dealing with
I'm sorry go ahead
to I think to that really gets to the
problem here is that is the pricing is
based on a negotiated contract and like
I say it could have been a you know in
one employer Arisa they got that volume
discount and to apply it to every
business relationship that you have is
impossible
um and so you know that I I'm not sure
how we can fix this problem because
that's the nature of what pbms do is
negotiate pricing and and so to
negotiate to you know as we all know if
you're if you're buying a hundred buying
a case of something you're going to get
a different price than if you're only
buying one of it or small of it so if
you only have one particular uh client
that's in your community who needs this
one obscure drug
and and insists on not getting it
through the mail order but insist on
buying it from you that you run this
risk of having to well that's one thing
I have law that says that they have to
reimburse me above my cost
they have to reimburse you that's what
it says here
already the current law correct we're
just asking to know where
uh where how to enforce it well no
that's that's another issue where no you
have to buy it where you have to know
where to buy it from right but but they
don't yeah
do they really know that that they that
that's the only way you can get that
price is you got to buy a case of it not
just one of it but I'm not allowed to
buy a case of it with another PBM right
because that violates that contract
right that's like I'm saying so it's
yeah it's it it really is a challenge
between a rock and a hard place here
well all they do is tell me where they
where I can buy it
yeah I don't think you can obviously no
no they they think they can say you can
buy it but the reality is even if you
were to call that wholesaler who had it
they say well that's fine but you got to
buy a case of it to get that price
in other words they're not factoring in
volume discount
no
well we do we are involved in buying
groups where we negotiate the best
prices that we can right it's not just
me with my small store and Glenn with
his larger store because you guys are
not a writer you're all Independents
right correct correct Independence our
Acquisitions our prices are very similar
except for a little bit of volume
difference and pricing but but not
significantly different
um and and as I grow based on the need
occurring which is where this is where
the problem is you know I get those
discounts but my losses continue to grow
as my business grows because of
of some some silly little issues of you
know this is what we say the cost is
we have determined that this is what the
cost is
we can look at some sort of compendium
and do a discount off of that price to
come up with what Mac is
they buy tons of drugs and know what the
prices are
well well tell me well what okay what
manufacture them that I can go to and
say okay you need to give me the same
price because
yeah okay so we're just asking for
information
you know and and and not part of this is
is the next step is trying to figure out
how do we get
the state to enforce
them to provide us
oh at cost or above I'm not sure how
many people here are business owners or
have budgets but but selling things at
below costs is not a very good business
plan
I mean I
you know I only went to a couple schools
well you theoretically you could say to
the customer I'm sorry I can't sell it
to you because I'm not going to get
reimbursed enough well the point is
that we're being forced down this road
of well how do we how do we stay alive
and if you look at the numbers I mean
it's not like Independents are growing
every day pharmacies are closing I mean
even the chains are closing I got it I'm
sorry okay representative Terry has one
more question so
the the Chairman's astute observation
notwithstanding but alongside and coming
back to the response given to me by one
of the previous folks who was testifying
the other Pharmacy owner
the question here is the problem is they
won't tell you where you can get it
correct right now you never get the
feeling that what they would like is for
you to just go away
and disappear well I think so everything
can be bail ordered that is for sure
correct okay let's just cut to the chase
thank you
okay representative Herbert has a
question
okay I'm sorry he's he's right-handed
yes right
I just want to I think what we're
looking at is a very complicated uh
semi-monopoly system which really isn't
in competition
and uh my question is is there a a
source that does in fact
uh is such a large buyer of drugs that
they get the best price the market will
well the the people there is there a
source that buys that much yes so we buy
from the three largest wholesalers in
the country I used to buy from the
largest distrib distributor of generic
drugs in the world
okay so I would think
that their pricing would be pretty good
yeah I was part of their uh organization
through a um
franchise
who was this that was McKesson McKesson
okay and drug companies well well
they're a wholesaler
and they also are psao
that negotiate the prices for us and yes
there is a there there's a cloud of
mystery there that why is it that are
you signing contracts when you know
that's not what you know the prices are
higher you know there's many layers to
this onion we're just trying to find out
where
they think we can get this
um my further question but we're not
buying it from a a little wholesaler
down the road that can't compete with
big guys I'm competing with
the I'm using the same Distribution
Systems I'm using the same Source the
same Supply channels except going direct
to the manufacturers which is probably
what the mail orders are doing
just one further question further
question
um
perchance does the federal government is
are they a customer
yes
it's called Medicare pardon me Medicare
Medicare okay Medicare well we they also
have a lot of people in defense that uh
not on Medicare yet but correct well we
have the state who's a very large
employer I'm just trying to get I'm just
trying to identify where you may be able
to get the information on not just a
need to know basis but a portal that
shows
all the pricing that's secret that well
okay that's the secret no the Dirty
Little Secret is not that anybody likes
each other there's that the whole point
of a negotiated price is that it's a
negotiated secret and so yes you're
you're gonna you're basically asking the
PBM to tell us their special formula of
what website special price they got with
that one particular manufacturer and
they don't want to tell you that can I
throw out a silly analogy that I thought
about this morning sure
so the regulation states that they have
to pay us
cost or better
now I have a lot of regulations that I
deal with
when I drive
there is nobody
standing by the side of the road that
says stop the speed limit is going to
change
look it up
figure out what it is because down the
road there's going to be somebody that's
going to you know bag you if you're not
right
let's not put a sign up
we're just gonna tell you and if you're
in a hurry you just blow by the guy
you're not going to go you're not going
to know why is it that we all have to
follow the rules
and here we have a proprietary situation
that has to be secret and we have to
make it all convoluted and and and and
we have to jump through hoops to make
sure that they are complying with the
rules
I think I think you look at an
Anti-Trust issue so well let's add a
whole nother layer would you believe
I think I think we got this one thank
you so much oh you're welcome you did
good job and I would be more than happy
to answer any questions in the future we
will be having a subcommittee on this
bill okay having no more cards I will
close the public hearing
on 383 and let's move right on to the
okay next up uh house bill 426.
relative to regulations of Pharmacists
in charge and pharmacies you know it's
okay
thank you Mr chairman
members of the committee you're going to
get all kinds of Pharmacy today
but I promise you I won't be back
somehow I think I could be scheduled for
another day I think you do yeah we'll
get this out of your way this one is
this the easy one this should be easy I
thought there was an easy one this
should be easy this should be easy I see
a lot of pink cards though so I think
that they should be all easy pick cards
um
so before you right now is HB 426 so
this bill actually was put forward as a
request from the Board of Pharmacy so in
addition to being a pharmacist I also am
vice president of the Board of Pharmacy
so the Board of Pharmacy has been
working since this summer
to
modernize some of our our Pharmacy
Practice Act to delineate how a permit
is issued and I know this typically
isn't doesn't
isn't business
um but it does relate to how a business
in pharmacy
is granted a permit so right now the way
it stands in the state of New Hampshire
and RSA 318 when the permit is issued to
a pharmacy is actually issued to a
pharmacist in charge or a pharmacist in
charge is the one who actually is is uh
um the the permit is issued to now the
concept of a pharmacist in charge goes
way back to when most pharmacies were
owned by Pharmacists and the state had
to have somebody to go to and hold
responsible if there was an issue
and uh so the issues that would arise
that a pharmacist in charge would be
responsible for could be as mundane as
whether or not there's hot and cold
running water whether or not there was
adequate Staffing whether or not the
roof leaked whether or not the door had
a lock on it whether or not the sign had
letters that were three inches tall I
mean that's the kind of stuff that's in
the pharmacy Practice Act I mean it's
it's it gets to be that mundane
the problem is you you get fast forward
to the year 2023 and most pharmacies in
the state of New Hampshire as we learn
about just a few minutes ago are not
owned by individuals anymore they're
owned by corporations or by hospitals so
to have an individual pharmacist in
charge be responsible for making sure
there's hot and cold running water when
many times that person has no authority
to call a plumber and hire a roofer or
or call a locksmith this is just a
modernization of that so the Board of
Pharmacy asked to put this bill forward
and what this does is it delineates a it
takes out of the pharmacist in charge
and it puts in a permit holder so
what we've done now is where their
pharmacists in charge was responsible
for certain activities and certain
responsibilities we've Rewritten the
bill Rewritten 318 and put that
responsibility under the permit holder
which essentially would be the owner or
that designated person within the bill
um
this has come again this this has been
when we put this bill together we
brought in a number of stakeholders this
has been supported like I said by the
New Hampshire Board of Pharmacy I think
you're going to hear from the New
Hampshire pharmacists Association or at
least they've signed in New Hampshire
Hospital Association the chain
pharmacists uh have supported the CVS
has supported this this has been run by
um some of the folks down on Amazon it's
a wildly supported concept it's a it's a
modern concept uh and it's one that I
think reflects uh the the current state
of Pharmacy
in in the times so with that I would be
happy to answer any questions that the
so this this bill probably should have
gone to Edna and normally would have
gone to Edna but I think that they had
so many bills and they knew we were
doing Pharmacy bills so you guys love
Pharmacy do we just we're getting a
little more boned up on the pharmacy
sure so but I don't think we have any
particular questions right it's very
straightforward thank you good job
okay
uh next is uh let's see do I have I have
I don't have any oh Gary Merchant
I have written testimony which I won't
read to you I'll leave that to your
pleasure sometime this evening or some
other time I also have a
written testimony from an attorney who's
also a pharmacist Richard Burdette I'm
in support of the bill as well hold on
for the record my name is Gary Merchant
I'm a representative represented in
Claremont and Croydon which is Sullivan
County District 6.
prior to serving in the house I served
on a New Hampshire Board of Pharmacy
along with representative roachford for
a period of time
of the 10 years the last two was serving
as the president of the board
this is really a simple
simple bill I'll just get it down to the
we need to find a way to align
accountability with authority
he who has the authority should be
accountable
as representative protrude said
it's a relic from the past
back in the 50s and 60s when a lot of
this came about
the owner of the pharmacy
was most likely the pick
so you had alignment between Authority
and responsibility and accountability
however over the years
as independent pharmacies were acquired
as Corporate America expanded locations
that alignment has been eroded to the
point today where the pharmacists in
charge still retains all the
accountability to the board
with extremely little if any Authority
they don't decide on the Staffing they
don't decide about the drugs what's
stored in the pharmacy they really have
very little authority outside of showing
up to work and doing what they're
supposed to do
I'll give you an example which is what
prompted a lot of this
we had a clap a case here in New
Hampshire which a pharmacist in charge
in a hospital
was held accountable
makes sense
however
we have documentation that they sent
requests to senior leadership asking for
resources
so the issue that arose would not arise
they were not supplied with the
resources
but the way the law is written
there is no Authority by the board
to hold a permit holder accountable
because they don't have accountability
they only have authority
so what this bill fundamentally does
it goes back to aligning accountability
with responsibility
number two if you look at the statute
today
the pharmacist in charge is not only
accountable for themselves
they're accountable
for all the pharmacists working within
the pharmacy
why would one pharmacist be accountable
over another pharmacist how they
practice
he wouldn't hold a position accountable
for another position
he wouldn't hurt hold the nurse
accountable for what another nurse does
so why do we do that with Pharmacy
so all I'm asking in support of the bill
is for you both to think how do we align
fundamentally if you have the authority
you have the accountability
and I'll see about my testimony written
nice seeing you
thank you
okay do we have any questions I think
it's pretty straightforward this is
brain
statute up to up to the current times
yeah sorry
yeah okay thank you very much uh Kathy
from the hospital Association so nice to
see you again nice to see you
good afternoon Mr chairman and members
of the committee my name is Kathy Bazar
with thunderberg I'm the Executive Vice
President New Hampshire Hospital
Association we represent all 26 acute
care hospitals in all specialty
hospitals in New Hampshire
we are in full support of House Bill 426
and as already mentioned the the
alignment between a permit holder and
allowing licensees to focus on their
scope of practice is really the the Crux
of this bill
um under the current statutory framework
all responsibilities of a pharmacy are
assigned uh to a pharmacy to a
pharmacist in charge which includes the
operations their own scope of practice
and those that work in the pharmacy many
times as already stated by
representative Rochford and Merchant
those operational decisions about how to
run a pharmacy are made at a different
level not themselves and but
unfortunately the Board of Pharmacy
holds the pick solely responsible for
everything we truly believe that
properly aligning Pharmacy operations as
the responsibility of the permit holder
and allowing the individual
professionals to be responsible for
their own actions and their scope of
practice is the most appropriate way to
structure Pharmacy and Pharmacy
regulations I really do urge you to
support at this bill happy to answer any
questions
thank you very much all right thank you
I do have written testimony which I will
share written testimony is great thank
you
thank you got one more card left Robert
thrall New Hampshire Society of Health
System
pharmacist
just a pharmacist won't go away
hi thank you good afternoon Mr chairman
and members of the committee my name is
Bob therio I'm the legislative chair of
the New Hampshire Society of Health
Systems pharmacists so we're a
professional organization that supports
uh the professional interests of
Pharmacists in all practice settings
hospitals Community Pharmacy
and Clinics and I'm here to support
house bills 426. I think uh their
representative Rose Shredder Merchant
and Kathy have framed uh the issue well
uh the pick language I've been a
pharmacist for over 40 years and the
pick language was around when I became a
pharmacist and so it is decades old and
archaic most pharmacies are either
managed or owned by a district or
Regional or corporate level and and and
most of the picks do not report to a
pharmacist I'm actually also the
director of Pharmacy and a pick at
Wentworth Douglas hospital and I report
to a chief nursing officer in our
hospital as part of a larger enterprise
system so oftentimes decisions are made
outside of even our our Hospital scope
so as you can see the decision making
and my authority and responsibility is
um broad ranging and I don't always have
the control that that I have as uh there
was a case as a representative Merchant
mentioned of a controlled substance uh
issue in the in the state of New
Hampshire and that pharmacist in charge
was held accountable and what came out
in part was the organization had not
renewed a contract for diversion
monitoring software and again that
pharmacist was held accountable for that
I don't know if you're
um
aware of chapter 797 where sterile
compounding most sterile compounding has
to be done in clean rooms clean rooms
require large sums of money for hvacs
and to build a clean room can be in the
million money for hvacs and to build a
clean room can be in the millions of
dollars and if I violate a clean room uh
statute it's my livelihood so bottom
line and I think what this bill does is
put the employer employee relationship
in line puts the accountability for the
permit holder where it should be and the
accountability for my license where it
should be so in essence I could lose my
livelihood to be practiced as a
pharmacist if I violated a pick or if my
organization violated a pick
responsibility I I did draft written
testimony and I will hand that for you
to you and if you have any questions I'm
happy to field them
thank you
all right having no more cards uh I
would say uh the blue sheet we have
everybody is in support including CVS
Health uh New Hampshire chain drug
stores
and the New Hampshire pharmacist
Association
we're all good
I will close the public hearing on 426
and now I go to our last spill of the
day
I'll spill 303
relative to insurance coverage for Pain
Management Services
is representative Nagel here oh there
Mr chairman I have a written statement I
would like to share that would be
wonderful all right makes the clerk very
happy
assistant
good afternoon ready yep okay thank you
Mr chairman and thank you for the
committee for our time
um I'd like to spend a little bit of
time uh introducing the bill introducing
myself and um giving you some
suggestions on where we should go from
here and thank you very much for your
time
um I've been a practicing physician in
New Hampshire now
um for roughly 33 years I started my
career at Easter Seals I moved on to
Concord Orthopedics my specialty is
physical medicine and rehabilitation I
work with people with complex
disabilities
um
um all the disabilities I deal with
involve some element of pain so I become
a pain management specialist somewhat by
default somewhat by Design
um about 30 years ago I realized that we
as a society don't treat these people
very well we stigmatize them and so I
became involved in advocacy first for
people with post-concussive syndrome
and then people with chronic pain and
that's been my passion for the last 30
years as part of that I initiated and
helped write the first opioid
prescribing rules for the state I
actually helped create the first the
acupuncture practice act as well
I also
um started two non-profits both devoted
to increasing access to therapies and
and supporting the needs of people in
pain
about seven years ago I was asked by the
NFL players Association to chair their
pain management committee and I've done
that for that period of time and I'm one
of the lead authors on their best
practices guide for how we manage pain
most importantly out of frustration I
wrote a book called needless suffering
how Society fails those with chronic
pain it was published seven years ago
and it's one of those yeah dub books
that basically tells us what we're doing
right what we're doing wrong and how
through creative public policy we can do
a lot better to help the people
um in need and basically it's because of
needless suffering that I wrote this
bill
um and I would be lying if I told you
um that I alone wrote this bill it's a
collaborative effort
um if you look on page two you list all
the organizations that sponsor this bill
um I'm involved with most of these the
one I want to draw your attention to is
the alliance to advance comprehensive
integrative pain management
um that's a group out of Kansas City and
they represent over 92 National
organizations including Health Care
Providers patient advocacy groups the
Department of Defense the VA and believe
it or not insurers as well
um
we've understood since we in this
country have understood since the 1980s
the pain management is best done in a
multimodal integrative manner what that
means is that somebody's running the
show and that we we provide a variety of
modalities simultaneously to help
maximize outcome and Pain Management
if you believe in eastern philosophy
which I do that is written as far as 220
BC it would be wonderful if that's what
we do but it's not what we do basically
what we do in our culture is we pay for
pills and procedures and and because of
that that's what we provide patients and
unfortunately it's not a very good way
of going about things there's nothing
integrative about it
none of these modalities really is shown
any long-term benefit and it's a huge
problem because in my world humbly and
somewhat grandiosely I see my role as
standing up for the rights of 66 million
Americans who suffer from chronic pain
1.5 million people are in Hospice at any
point in their life
the tens of millions of people that
suffer moderate to severe acute pain and
also there's about 50 million post-op
patients per year all these people
require some element of pain management
and I don't think that we're doing a
very good job with that so the system's
not working
and as of 2011 The Institute of medicine
came up with a number that we quote over
and over again it's probably a lot
higher now but that costs our society
and loss productivity medical costs Etc
650 million dollars a year so the point
is what that we really need to do better
and what we've created for ourselves are
a number of crises number one we have a
crises in over opioid prescription we
simultaneously have a crisis in under
opioid prescription we have an epidemic
of costly procedures we have a crisis of
costly inefficient Health Care
particularly those who suffer from
complex disabilities we have a crisis
dependency and lack of individual
empowerment and that was a big issue in
our committee of Health and Human
Services the other day trying to fix
that problem it also fuels the mental
health crises the likelihood a person
with chronic pain will successfully
commit suicide is three times that of
the normal population Nation
nobody seems to care about that and that
really bothers me a lot it's something
that's really important seventy percent
of people with chronic pain will have
comorbid depression and other and
anxiety disorders and other things that
are very treatable that we don't treat
and we don't help them with to address
these issues I'm going to read from all
to address these issues the Center for
Disease Control and the health and human
Department of Health and Human Services
separately created best practices guide
for pain management the CDC guide on
opioid prescribing came out in 2016 was
revised a couple months ago the HHS
guide came out um in 2019 I was honored
to be part of all of those um
um mostly with commentary
um but the big thing that came out of
these is yeah opioids have value but we
need to watch them but also that we need
to increase access to a variety of
therapies that we refer to as
alternative therapies including manual
therapies restorative therapies which
means exercise of some sort
Chiropractic Physical Therapy we neglect
the psychologic aspects of managing pain
way too often and they're extremely
critical in managing people with
depression how to reform the way they
look at their pain things like that
also Eastern forms of exercise are
really amazing like I had a 90 year old
lady come in to see me today that all I
needed to do to improve her balance was
to get her in a Tai Chi program and
something very simple like that and and
we don't do that and so what happens we
give her Gabapentin she gets dizzy she
falls and now she's got a broken hip and
a year later she's dead I mean that's
just totally not exciting acceptable but
that is the way we manage pain
I'm not going to go over the details of
HB 303 I'll leave that up to you but
what I wanted to say this is what it
does do and I'm going to say again this
is a collaborative effort with a lot of
people all over the country I'm not that
legislatively smart these people are
much smarter than I am and we worked on
this together which is really exciting
and these are people from all different
disciplines but what it does is
increases access to a broad array of
cost-effective evidence-based therapies
provided by licensed practitioners and
we've already went over the different
modalities involved it empowers
individuals which is incredibly
important with the skills that they need
to control their lives it gives the
potential which is really important to
prevent chronic pain because right now
we cannot do that and we do not do that
and we do not do a good job of that
also we've had a lot of discussions with
insurers about this issue and they're
exciting I really like talking to them
I've learned an awful lot about their
side of the world but it creates some
level of transparency because what
they'll say is a lot of these services
are offered and I don't disagree with
that but they're not offered in a
transparent way we the providers don't
see that like if they have this
insurance what can I do for this person
that person or the other person and that
transparency issue is critical it
transitions away from expensive pills
and procedures that have limited
efficacy and you're listening to a
hypocrite say this because I am an
Interventional pain specialist
God bless me everyone it does not
eliminate allopathic therapies they
still have their value but they need to
be part of whole person care
so as a part of the comprehensive
addiction recovery Act of 2016 the VA
was charged to create a charter program
that would look at this to see can this
work and I just talked to Ben kligler
from the VA today to get their outcome
data on that to make sure that I wasn't
missing something and Ben told me and
it's also published data so you can see
this number one the people in their
program that provided access to these
services and when I did visit the VA
here in Manchester they do have access
to Chiropractic acupuncture mindfulness
meditation all that stuff they found out
there's a 38 percent reduction in opioid
use and while I think some people need
opioids every patient I've ever been on
who has on them would rather not be on
them so it gave them an alternative
strategy to manage their pain 30 percent
reduction in Interventional stuff that's
where you save the money if I'm not
doing a thirty five hundred dollar
injection and this person can manage
their pain without relying me that's
what I want I want to go out of business
that would be the best for me I know
you're a Commerce Committee and you're
supposed to promote business I want to
go out of business
less anxiety depression less medication
use especially interestingly for psych
meds and improved quality of life
what I want to close by saying I want to
share a story I run a non-profit we're
looking at a whole life whole person
approach to athletic perform or
participation pain is a huge issue that
we deal with I did a focus group with a
bunch of NFL players who are on um
uninjured reserve and the first question
we asked them which I already knew the
name of the answer to was do you trust
your doctor
and the answer was an expletive no very
loud and then the one guy looked at me
he was 20 years four years old said I
don't trust any doctor and it wasn't
based on just him it was his family
experience dealing with pain and other
related issues and the re and then I
said him I go why is that he goes
because all they're interested in is
giving me a pill or a procedure that I
know isn't going to help me
and and they're more interested in their
bottom line than they are in me
and then I looked at Milan what what do
you do and then without being um at all
uh I'm gonna brag a little bit here but
anyways without prompting at all he
basically outlined hb303 all the
modalities that he uses to manage his
pain he is an NFL player getting access
to care is not an issue but I've talked
to retired players where we did focus
groups as well and they said it's a
shock when they leave that locker room
for the last time and find out that they
don't have access to these things that
they've relied on their entire career to
function
um this is an opportunity for us we have
been charged by patients families
providers governments agencies Etc to
provide responsible
patient-centered integrative
interdisciplinary cost effective
broad-based care that's a run-on
sentence for those who suffer and who
too needlessly from chronic pain
this bill was developed in collaboration
with thoughtful mindful people who I'm
honored to represent many of whom are
here behind me today
um
as far as I'm concerned if the HHS or
and the CDC have anything to do with it
we as providers are ready for this and
we would really like the insurers to
assist us in that process and I'll be
two questions
this this one is
to get an opinion first of all it seems
like we're attacking the problem kind of
like from the bottom instead of from the
top and as a result of that since so
many people in my age group
and I'm going to say yours but it is
mine
we might be closer than you think we're
not going to get any help out of
Medicare or Medicaid
but just not you know so whatever laws
we pass here
it people in my age group and on we're
not going to get anything from it
the second but my question then is this
you mentioned licensed practitioners yes
so I looked that up
based on
the practitioners that you talk about
yoga uh chidung and a few other things
they are not licensed that is somewhat
correct but this is how I would qualify
that
um I would take yoga out of this that
was kind of shouldn't have been in there
okay the nice thing about yoga though is
it's available to anybody but I will
tell you I I did talk to a Hindu yoga
master I don't know what they officially
call themselves and I asked them what
kind of yoga do you recommend for back
pain and he said I don't
um we have a really strange idea of what
yoga is in the United States um it's not
really what they think of in Hindu
culture some of the movement patterns
really aren't good for those type of
people but we've modified it a lot but
you can go online there's all sorts of
access to it it's not a big deal to
access yoga Tai Chi maybe but um Qigong
and things like that almost all the
people I've known that do Qigong were
instructed by acupuncturists who are
licensed and they would do that as a
part of their thing the acupuncturists
are but they themselves are not anybody
can hang a shingle out there and say I'm
going to teach this stuff oh the state
of New Hampshire say that again State of
New Hampshire you don't need a license
or a certification of any kind oh you're
correct you're correct acupuncture you
certainly do I thought that's what you
were saying I'm sorry no chidan you
don't Tai Chi you don't and yoga you
don't that's where I'm having a little
bit of a problem trying to as a as a
customer said say finding someone
legitimate and how would an insurance
company find someone legitimate because
they're responsible for
supplying these people I could respond
to that in another way
um when we designed this bill I've been
involved with insurers and talking about
this for a long time and I realize we're
very much on different sides of this
issue but I do think it's important
societally to come together on these
issues so I will say that this is a
compromise bill it's nowhere's near what
I would like but it is what I know what
what other states
I assume this is model legislation
that's just being presented um Cindy
Steinberg from the U.S Payne Foundation
worked on this bill with me and she
wrote a similar somewhat similar
legislation in Massachusetts there's
other bills in other states there's a
project going on in Vermont right now
that the alliance advance and the VA is
very much involved in creating models of
care like that I will tell you I I um
I've been here for 33 years I've always
believed in integrative care whether it
was handling stroke spinal cord injury
pain whatever
um
when um when I started out we actually
created this model by ourselves with no
oversight what I would what I mean
there's no umbrella organization we
didn't call ourselves God's Gift of pain
management or something we didn't have a
name we just did it and so what what
I've tried to do is to replicate that
model and I'm really frustrated by
barriers getting in our ways well this
Hospital doesn't want to work with that
hospital without private insurer it's a
crazy system you know if we're gonna
have a market-based system we need to
have barriers that don't exist that we
can collaborate with each other and part
of this bill is also to break down those
you uh am I allowed to answer her other
question that she comment of course okay
I'm sorry I don't see I can't read that
um we do have a talk our Healthcare is
wrong it's it's it's a pyramid like that
read my book there's an entire chapter
on redoing the entire Health Care system
that focuses on management of problems
not proceduralizing it fragmentation is
a huge problem in our Health Care system
and it's because we're like that not
like that
okay so uh representative representative
Sullivan sure go ahead
thank you Mr chairman uh yeah I just
have one quick question which is if we
already paid for a lot of these so at
least some of these things that we pay
for like physical therapy and
chiropractor care that's generally
considered normal normally covered by
insurance companies so
why what is the resistance to it now
specifically if if what you say is true
that that um they could save money like
you said you could get this done for
whatever versus a 3 500 shot seems like
a no-brainer so there's got to be a good
reason why we haven't moved to in this
direction organically I think I would
have to defer that question of the
insurers I think I mean you you all know
I mean
I sat down and made a Venn diagram about
our entire Health Care System about how
all these little pieces fit into each
other because there's a staying for
every complex problem social problem
there's a solution that's neat simple
and wrong so I was trying to figure out
like how all these things fit together
and answer that question there's no
simple answer to that which is
unfortunate one of the things that I've
observed in all the years that I've been
here number one is 30 years ago when we
wanted to communicate we actually picked
up a telephone we don't do that anymore
but which is a huge problem in medicine
because we don't communicate anymore but
but the other thing is that when we
started out chiropractors would be
allowed to have almost an unendable
number of visits with people and then
then it was 20 visits then it was 12
visits then some insurers at six visits
and other visits none then others you
need to have prior authorization that
will allow you five visits but after
five you have to submit another thing
and then when you do that at extend
extensive cost then you find out three
months later you've been approved to do
some more and by that time anything you
started with is lost and I had to deal
with that issue with acupuncture it it's
not a good system and
and the crazy thing that we had talked
about earlier today is increa we don't
pay for psych Service as well I think we
all know that mental health in the
States and it's not just the New
Hampshire it's all the countries a
problem access to care all these things
are important um 20 visits is really
nothing
um I don't know why
if you can answer it I'd be happy to
hear that was a very long answer for an
so we will have a subcommittee and uh
yes I can tell you why when we do the
subcommittee okay representative spear
we touched on it but we didn't really
but you didn't answer it and maybe you
don't know the answer but there were
three
the yoga that uh chi dung and the Tai
Chi are not licensed so how would even I
asking you as a personal question how
would I even find somebody since I don't
know who's qualified and anybody can
hang up a shingle I mean I tend to have
my little network of referral people
that I trust
um but you're right I mean even an
acupuncturist I mean you can go to the
board of licensure this or a doctor even
for that matter this I might trust some
I don't trust but that's certainly true
yeah with it but then I have a recourse
with these other folks I don't and so
I'm wondering how you would expect an
insurance company
to be able to provide them
um my answer to what would they go to
yeah my answer is that those things
should not have been in that bill so I
would probably amend it to take those
out
yeah in an Ideal World I would we have
the same issue with personal trainers
um exercise and restorative care is
really important it's probably the most
important of anything in this bill we
didn't include personal trainers because
there's no licensure and to be honest
for the same reason those three things
should not have been in there for that
same reason
but it's had that build in the past
what's that we've had that bill in the
past yeah for personal trainers yes
I'm sorry I missed that we've had that
legislation to mandate uh Health a third
party insurance reimbursement for for
personal trainers well for uh athletic
trainers yeah is that some interest
representative Yemen
thank you Mr chair thank you for your
testimony thank you uh I just have a
question for of clarification on page
uh what page is this is one bill of the
Bill of the bill yeah
you know
go ahead and say my video doesn't have
the lines on it no it doesn't it's so
it's uh Roman numeral two under section
one
um but it says uh
shall provide for at least 20 visits and
shall include coverage for coordination
of Pain Management Services during the
plan year and then it says for each of
the preceding Pain Management Services
to manage pain so proceeding would be
that list that we've been talking about
yes so the way I read this is one
interpretation could be it could mandate
20 visits for each of those different
which could be you know I don't know 200
300 different visits is is that how you
meant that's not the intent the intent
was 20 total
okay
be honest if I have a wish list it would
be 20 for each
no
I'm happy to change it
okay
thank you very much
so uh representative who put in a bill
last year yes you're you're a rep so you
now last year your bill was yoga do we
have yoga yes
thank you I'm representative manjipuri
from Nashua Hillsborough 11. this is the
third term that this kind of bill with
not my name on it this time
has appeared so basically what this bill
is attempting to do is turn the Pyramid
of Health Care System upside down if you
all know how the nutrition thing was
pyramid with you know bottom was grains
and now it's upside down do the protein
on top and well fat so basically a
current a healthcare system is disease
based
and
treating the disease
so this attempts to Integrative Medicine
looking at a person not my left hand my
right hand The Specialist my right eye
go to the left eye specialist to treat
your
left eye problem not the right eye kind
of thing but this is looking at a whole
person who's dealing with pain and
preventive early intervention a holistic
approach to what's available instead of
doing a piecemeal so
I've tried in several different forms
first first term I presented it to
introduced it to uh Health and Human
Services and
um
committee and uh also worked
with one of the health health insurance
folks
provider I won't name the name to do a
pilot how it can be impactful so
it's it's different it's it's not very
different but if you look at human
beings in what we are treating this
makes a lot of sense
um
so I'll give you an example my husband
has a chronic back pain
and he has gone for multiple MRIs and
you know his claustrophobic so they have
to put him under to put them through CT
scan or MRI and he dreads that and so
the diagnosis is okay you do not have
any joint issue you do not have any uh
tumor or anything thank goodness but
they are not able to pinpoint what it is
so
they can do surgery
and other than taking medication he says
no I don't want to take painkillers
extended period of time and so he has to
function he's a public school teacher
and he has to function as an individual
so finally he started going you know we
both are yoga practitioners and you know
we come from a place where yoga capital
of the world
and um
so this whole integrated approach it has
all taken uh in the manipulative
osteopathic manipulation he fixed the
problem in two settings and to maintain
it
in that way was
yeah yoga physical therapy and
um chiropractor this is what it took
five years
of going through we had a good insurance
thank goodness
and we could do that
and the amount of money is spent on that
if we had started this
intuitively say okay can we do this but
you know it wasn't available it's not a
mainstream
so these are I mean
this Integrative Medicine in the Eastern
medicine it is part of practice everyday
practice how do I license
and make it quantitative
billable unit
is a challenge
and I'm persisting with that so I
give all kudos to
representative Nagel because he and I
have been sitting on this committee for
eight years now
so
I would encourage if we can do a
subcommittee I can give you a lot of
models that can work so I'm still
working on that to get some funding for
to do a pilot and show some significant
evidence base it's like chicken or the
egg come first what comes first
unless you have a pilot study or Pilot
to do it you can show an Evidence all
you have is anecdotal
so prevention is an ounce of prevention
is better than a pound of cure it was
100 years ago it's today and it will be
tomorrow thank you
uh we do have a question representative
Yemen has a question
representative benjibouti uh you you may
remember you and I were seat mates for
four years in the in the house so
well good to see you uh the previous
speaker the prime sponsor said uh he
considers removing he would consider
removing yoga Qigong and Tai Chi from
the bill is that your position
no what I would say is because there is
no clear path of Licensing that appeared
to kyoga okay there are therapeutic yoga
providers that do exist but there is no
board but there are other states or
other places that have done it so I can
get you some information on that
great thank you very much
okay
um
[Music]
okay I'll keep her around here
so next up I have here is Amy Odell
Wilson from the New Hampshire
acupuncture
good afternoon thank you for allowing me
to speak
my name is Amy Odell Wilson I'm a
licensed acupuncturist and also a Qigong
instructor I'm the vice president of the
New Hampshire acupuncture and Asian
medicine Society
and we do stand in support of this bill
HB 303
we're here today because we are Pain
Care Specialists and it is our
collective experience that acupuncture
Qigong and Tai Chi when used together
with other pain management protocols
improve outcomes
many of those have already been
mentioned but um
I want you to just reiterate that every
Protocol no matter what it is for pain
management has its shortcomings and when
it's used in conjunction with other
therapies
we were able to reduce or avoid
medications altogether
we reduce negative side effects we speed
up recovery
we correct the root cause
and we reduce anxiety and depression
acupuncture is underutilized
less than nine percent of the insured
and listening to the others speak going
off script a little bit to address some
of the things that have been brought up
foreign
last night and this is a hard copy but
also connected to it there's some
research bullets I know your time is
very valuable and you don't always have
I'll let that pass around
and talk to speak to this specifically
about Qigong that was raised
I believe that although Qigong in New
Hampshire is not a licensed criteria
acupuncturists who are licensed were
trained at school
to practice it and currently
um
if we're reimbursed by insurance for
acupuncture were not reimbursed for
Qigong
and yet it's medical uh protocol and so
in thinking about that I would ask that
you don't take Qigong out of this bill
but in fact you would allow
acupuncturists who are trained
to be reimbursed for this service also
and then if you draw your attention to
the second to last paragraph of the
first page
also addressing the question that people
over 65 who are on Medicare don't have
access to acupuncture
it's coming
um as of December you might not be aware
that the no pain Act was passed at the
federal level it become effective in
2025 and this will mandate at the
federal level in Medicare that
non-pharmaceutical and non-addictive
and then if you flip
um
to the back to the second research
bullet that I have there
you were asking if there's other models
out there that this has happened and Dr
Nagel
talked about some in the state but there
are actually five in the world that have
been looked at
um and two points of that you'll see
that not only
the UK but Germany Switzerland China and
the US have models for this
but also in their research they came
they noticed that the economics can
rarely be the only thing that's
considered we really have to look at the
long-term outcomes of this
and that's because it takes such a long
time to fully understand the health
economics and in the meantime people
also you may or may not know that
Medicare currently covers acupuncture
however
it's not really convenient since
acupuncturists are not Medicare
providers
and so under the current system it
covers low back injury
if it's Insidious
if it's more if the pain has been there
for more than 12 weeks
and
if you're seen by a medical doctor which
we're not under the
license of a medical doctor
but the only way an acupuncturist can
get reimbursement for Medicare at this
time is if the medical doctor gets paid
and then pays the acupuncturist I don't
know any system or any medical doctor
who's going to go through that
so yes it's out there but only a medical
doctor who performs acupuncture at this
time are the ones who can get reimbursed
by Medicare
that's hopefully changing we do have a
bill that will be in the House of
and
the U.S house yes the federal house
um and the last thing just to put out
there may be one of the most important
parts of this is that when Insurance
recognizes the importance of these
modalities
media grabs a hold of it
more people become aware of it more
people trust it more people will find
access to it and then it'll spread and
then you'll see the economic economic
results
representative thank you chairman my
question is this protocol that you speak
about that uses several modalities of
treatment
um
if we were to permit say licensed
acupuncture but omit the others is that
going to cause a serious hardship for
the treatment plans that you have
organized and have arranged that you
found effective
so I can speak to
um my
the way I work and patients that I work
with
and I'll tell you two specific stories
but very short
when people have access
to acupuncture Qigong Physical Therapy
Massage
yoga it's a wrap around service and
people find the care that they need
because no pain is exactly the same
no person is exactly the same and what
their access
what they're capable of is not the same
so in two instances really quickly I
work primarily with the geriatric the
senior population probably the average
age of my patients is 75.
I have one individual 80 years old he's
been on gabapentin for neuropathy
pain for over 30 years and the problem
with that is it causes dizziness and all
of you know that dizziness is a high
risk for Falls
and when we when you have a fall and
you're 80 years old you're part of a
medical system and that's expensive
so his quest has been to reduce his
dizziness by getting off a Gabapentin
over the past year he's received regular
acupuncture he's in my Qigong class and
he's gone from 9 900 milligrams of big
Gabapentin down to zero in a year and a
half he's no longer is it dizzy because
of Qigong his balance has improved and
because he's off Gabapentin he's no
longer dizzy so his quality of life has
soared
another person is 70 years old she was
diagnosed with Insidious
nerve pain and spasticity
she was falling every single day and
walking with two walking sticks
um she ran into roadblocks she started
to see me started my Qigong class
she only walks with a cane on occasion
her doctor has recently just told her
that if it weren't for Qigong and
acupuncture she would be in a wheelchair
today
so is there any insurance company or any
employer that's now reimbursing you know
for
there are insurance companies
um that do reimburse blue class and Blue
Shield
Cigna
the interesting thing about that is
because they're not mandated those are
writers and depending on the employer
they choose or
choose not to have the acupuncture
writer or any other writer
so I wouldn't call it a writer what that
is those are large employers that are
self-insured so they have decided to add
that to their plans Okay so
it's not a mandate so people are
choosing not the individual who's being
insured but a bigger organization is
choosing whether someone has access or
some large employers are doing it you
have
yes and then on a personal experience
Cigna was in the state a couple of years
back they were trying to get more
acupuncturists involved in the plan
and yet they were offering different
acupuncturists different reimbursements
different rates and so I can't say that
a lot of acupuncturists signed on to
that because one the reimbursement was
so low and then also the fact that they
were choosing to give different people
different reimbursements
take note George
okay
are there any other questions thank you
very much thank you okay so let's change
our Pace a little bit and hear from the
insurance companies
uh so Heidi why don't you
good afternoon Mr chairman and members
of the committee for the record my name
is Heidi Kroll I work at Gallagher
Callahan and gartrell and I represent
ahip which is America's health insurance
plans we are the trade Association for
the health insurance carriers here in
New Hampshire
um thank you very much for the
opportunity to testify
um
uh as you might imagine we are opposed
to House Bill 303 um for reasons which I
will explain
um and we would respectfully request
that you find this bill in expedient to
legislate
um first and foremost we do think that
the bill is unnecessary we are not aware
of any other state where this extremely
broad set of mandates exist
carriers in New Hampshire already do
offer a variety of health plans that
cover a range of treatment alternatives
to opioids both medications as well as
medic alternative medications to opioids
as well as non-medication options
and a variety of informational
educational resources and materials as
well both to members and providers but
as you might imagine carriers offer
different plans with different covered
benefits which result in different
premiums and so members can choose the
plan that best meets their needs and
their budgets
we did a little
we've had a number of bills and I have
that later in my testimony we've had a
number of bills over the years on this
topic most recently there was an ad hoc
work group that was working on this over
the summer as a result of a piece of
legislation last year and we kind of did
a little survey of our active members
here so Chiropractic Services Physical
Therapy occupational therapy and tens
units seem to be universally covered
under a hip members standard plans
coverage for acupuncture and gym
memberships do vary by plan
plans typically do not cover massage
outside of a covered Chiropractic PT or
OT visit
meditation is not covered but it is
included in the carriers Health and
Wellness Resources and I did bring a
copy for myself but if you go on to any
of the plans websites you will find that
they have meditation and mindfulness
resources that are made available to
members and and to the public as well
including podcasts and things like that
there's also a list at least that found
one on Harvard Pilgrim's website it was
many many pages long about the
alternative medications to opioids that
they cover as well
and of course a variety of Behavioral
Health Services
as representative amond kind of picked
up on House Bill 303 lists approximately
by my count about 18 Services
which would are all seem to be qualified
by the phrase including but not limited
to indicating that there are unknown
number of other services Beyond those
listed and we did have the same concern
that if you were to mandate coverage for
a minimum of 20 visits for each of the
services listed as well as those not
listed but even if you try to narrow
that down if you were to do this across
every single Health Plan offered by
carriers that would have upward pressure
on the premiums for everyone and the
fiscal note does Echo
that point
um
it's also important to note because
because the bill looks to impose new
mandates in the individual Market that
exceed the state's Benchmark plan the
state would also face a new Financial
um
um there were some questions earlier
about this it is important to remember
that the bill proposes to impose new
mandates only on the fully insured uh
individual small group and large group
markets which account for less than 25
percent of New Hampshire's market so in
addition to the fully insured there's
also
self-funded employer coverage there's
Medicare Medicaid military coverage
people covered by out-of-state employers
so that would not be impacted by this
man set of mandates and of course the
uninsured so we're really talking about
putting potentially some upward pressure
on premiums paid by New Hampshire
citizens who are in the individual
Market or premiums paid by New Hampshire
small to mid-size employers
um another point is that covered
services from the plans perspective
should always be evidence-based Services
um and they're you know based on
clinical and scientific the key word
evidence-based right
um and so uh there's a concern that this
bill would override that important
criteria and as some of you may know
carriers do have independent review
boards they're continually reviewing
evidence and efficacy around medications
and treatments and services and they
um you've also touched upon this another
concern we had is that
um there's mandates for coverage of
services that would not be provided by
licensed and credentialed on clinical
providers and as we mentioned no medical
licensing or credentialing process for
things like yoga chai Kong Tai Chi
aquatic exercise meditation training
things like that and carriers networks
are obviously a fundamental aspect of
insurance coverage including the network
adequacy statutory licensing and
credentialing requirements quality of
care standards as you might recognize
you know our stamp of approval on
providers in the network means something
to the members and of course the
negotiated reimbursement rates
and as I mentioned when I first started
we have had several bills
um in the past as well as actually two
others this session
um dealing with these similar issues
um the two that are in this session
actually are how we're trying referred
to house HHS
one is relative to alternatives to
opioids
um it has five sections uh the first one
is not an insurance mandate but the
other four of five are and they look
very very similar to this bill
um it's a sponsored by representative
Lundgren but representative Nagel is
also a co-sponsor of that
so just wanted to make you aware of that
bill again that was House Bill 554 it
does have an FN on it as well there's
another bill House Bill 666 establishing
a commission to study
non-pharmacological treatment options
for patients with chronic pain that was
also sent to house HHS same two sponsors
as House Bill 303 has that was an
outcome of House Bill 247 from last year
relative to treatment alternative to
opioids and as I mentioned
um that was actually a 2021 bill I think
it was retained in a 2022 and they
created an ad hoc group just kind of
people willing to get together over the
summer which led to the idea of having a
commission on this
we've had two others I think or three
others in the past House Bill 1464 from
the 2019 session that was relative to
insurance coverage of yoga that was not
recommended for future legislation by
this committee I believe on a vote of 14
to 1 and that was when the Democrats
were in the majority the current
chairman was actually not chairman at
the time
SB 708 relative to treatment alternative
to opioids that died on the table and in
2019 House Bill 610 again relative to
treatment alternative to opioids that
was it yelled by house HHS actually on a
22-0 vote
so we've covered this issue you know
lots of times in the past and I think
for the reasons that I've outlined here
today it's just given people some some
pause and some um
heartburn I guess about going with such
a broad mandate so I'm happy to answer
any questions and uh so given that this
bill only affects the small group we
know it we would have to take the
individual piece out because State's not
going to pay cover that so if it only
the small group is there any benefit in
here that the small group I guess I'm
thinking we know the chiropractory is
covered up to 12 visits a year
is there anything else is like uh
acupuncture is there anything some that
is in the small group Market that
someone could get that in the small
group market today so the ACT
the ACT varied by plan when we was when
we surveyed um Harvard Pilgrim Anthem
and Cigna
um and I do know I think it was
referenced by the prior speaker but um
at least in the case of one carrier
um did it maybe more did a full sweep of
trying to get acupuncturists to join the
network
um last summer I think and and struggled
with with that so fighting providers
right but it varies by plan so not not
everything so technically there's two
things now that's you know one is the
Chiropractic which we did mandate the
you know the 12 visits and then the
others but the acupuncture is now
voluntarily
it's in some plans and it's not in
others so if it's an important service
for somebody that
um right you know from an employer
perspective because I know in the past I
think once with natural pass
I did May is may still in the statute or
is that did that get switched to showers
it may for a natural path to be your
primary care physician is that still in
the statute
would have to double check I don't
recall it being changed from me but I so
that is something we have done in the
past is just is put in May rather than
shall
and we did that for natural pass that's
thank you very much thank you
okay James
foreign
good afternoon good afternoon hello
I'd like to thank the committee for
allowing me to testify on behalf of the
New Hampshire Chiropractic Association
and I am in favor of house bill 303.
um
my name is James Pamplin I've been a
practicing chiropractor for over 20
years in New Hampshire
during that time I'm also a member of
the board of the New Hampshire
Chiropractic Association
um during my 20 years practicing I have
unfortunately seen a gradual decline in
um
this has resulted in my practice
canceling contracts for seven out of the
10 major insurance carriers
the reason for this decision was based
on four issues
the first was that we are seeing higher
co-pays that are now
um exceeding the benefit payouts for
each visit
so patients aren't getting much of a
benefit from insurance when their
co-pays are 40 50 60 dollars
number two deductible
are
deductible increases are now eclipsing
any cost and treatment plans that we
would prescribe to our patients
number three related more specifically
to this bill is Insurance visits
limits
um
are less than what is needed in order to
relieve the patient's symptoms or
prevent relapses
number four again related to this bill
is that essential services like re-exams
or extremity adjustings adjusting
um
especially with re-exams where it's
required for patient safety
um is no longer being reimbursed when
services are done on the same day
um these are fiscal or financial burdens
to
most of your constituents
and they
um
they pose
a very
real and significant obstacle to
um
so
Chiropractic Care is evidence-based it's
been proven in many studies to be safer
more effective
um
and so the bottom line is is that
your constituents shouldn't have to pay
higher insurance premiums for less
quality Chiropractic Care
um and that's
why I'm in support of this bill and I
thank you for your time
so what is in this bill that's different
than the Chiropractic mandate that we
already have in our statute
this uh promotes 20 uh Insurance uh
visits but in terms of it doesn't solve
the problem the co-pays deductibles and
anything like that actually doesn't all
it does is go from 12 to 20. it also uh
hopefully will cover more services that
are essential like uh re-exams and uh
um extremely adjusting and and maybe
some other answers isn't that in the 12
right just trying to understand the
difference
okay questions
okay I'll switch back to an insurance
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee I see some familiar faces and
lots of new ones uh for the record uh
Peter Bragdon I'm a senior policy
advisor with pretty strategies
representing uh Harvard Pilgrim
Healthcare a not-for-profit health
insurance company I think perhaps the
only not-for-profit insurance company
certainly the largest not-for-profit
insurance company
um and though we're opposed to the bill
we are strong supporters of non-opioid
Pain Management Service as evidenced by
the fact that we offer a wide variety of
these services to our members already
and we're opposed to the bill for for
five reasons first of all and some of
these were covered by by Heidi earlier
so I won't go into much detail uh but
first we feel it's not needed because as
noted we already cover a wide variety of
non-opioid Pain Management Services for
instance all of our plans cover Physical
Therapy occupational therapy all of our
individual and small group plans cover
Chiropractic acupuncture as well as we
also cover a wide range of of non-opioid
medications themselves as Alternatives
so these are already provided we don't
provide coverage for mediation services
provided by somebody external however as
Heidi mentioned we do have a website
available with a lot of resources on
mindfulness and mediation resources
including articles and actual recordings
of guided meditations so we provide
Alternatives where we can especially on
the area areas where it might be tough
to find a as was brought up before
licensed providers although
chiropractors and acupuncturers
acupuncturists are licensed by the state
there's a lot of things on here that are
not and so we provide some resources to
help in that area the second reason
we're opposed is certainly creates
mandates and we feel mandates increase
costs one size does not fit all we offer
a variety of plans with various benefit
levels including different coverage
levels for things allows us to meet the
needs of our our members while also
allowing them to meet their budgetary
needs
as mentioned before requiring Services
as the bill is written for 20 visits for
each of a dozen or more different types
of services will certainly be a
significant cost increase and as
mentioned also would also impact the
state budget because there's 50 000
people that get their insurance off the
state exchange for which the state would
have to pay for any of these increased
costs in premiums as a result
number three reason lack of
credentialing licensing and oversight we
are strongly opposed to any coverage
mandate where we would not be able to
determine if the provider is safe and
qualified to treat our members as I
mentioned some of these provide services
on here are already licensed and we
cover those so chiropractors
acupuncturists Etc but there's many that
are not
similar to that discussed before was the
the need for evidence-based Services we
have a duty to our members to make sure
we are covering services that have been
studied to determine they are effective
and cost efficient because after all
it's those members who are paying for it
so we look for evidence-based studies to
show that these are effective and
efficient services and for many of these
things list in the bill we are not aware
of any broad studies proving that these
servers are effective or cost efficient
and finally this bill goes beyond well
beyond what other states do it was
represented to you that a similar bill
is in uh has actually passed in
Massachusetts the Massachusetts Law
requires carriers to ensure they cover
at least two alternative medications and
at least three non-medication treatment
options it doesn't specify which ones
they have to cover it allows the
carriers the flexibility they need to
determine the mix of services this bill
prescribes dozen or so treatments that
have to be provided to everybody the
Massachusetts bill is is nothing like
this so for the reasons stated above we
again we support alternatives to the
pain
non-opioid pain Services about we feel
this bill just does not does not get our
support
happy to answer any questions Mr
chairman
so did Harvard support that
Massachusetts bill I was not uh
registered as a lobbyist in
Massachusetts I
cannot tell you
right well I guess the question is is
were the in that mandate it was two and
three were those things that you guys
offer
would you be able to comply with that if
we had passed that who passed that in
New Hampshire would you be if we'd be
able to comply with it yeah because I
think we already do offer these
Alternatives Bingo okay
um
anybody who's done
um what I would call
research on the exogenous
effects of not providing this uh these
Services Research on what
exogenous in other words Psych the oil
industry
they don't have to pay for the pollution
that's
created by oil
and I'm trying to think if anybody's and
and there are studies on that I was just
wondering if there are any studies that
somebody attempted to
um go into and do a study where the
services are not provided
and the impacts
that creates the costs that recreates uh
whereas they could do it uh you know
another study that would show that those
costs were ameliorated these are
external costs that are not put into the
budget is what I'm getting at right
right so thank you I don't I'm not aware
of a study that does that we get a lot
of anecdotal
uh in fact I don't know anybody that
couldn't give you an anecdote that uh
yoga or stretching on you know on your
own in your living room has helped uh
relieve pain so
but nobody's it doesn't sound to me like
anybody's actually done a serious
academic uh look at these external costs
oh yeah thank you for your question I'm
not aware of some of the the sponsor of
this bill maybe uh can shed some light
on that as well I will mention too
something I know what I made during some
of the testimony is you had a lot of
anecdotal incidents brought up where
somebody who is 70 years old got this
treatment and uh wanted me able to a
number of them they all the other ones I
heard dealt with people on Medicaid this
bill doesn't affect anybody on Medicaid
Medicare sorry Medicare not Medicare not
Medicaid not vets not large self-insured
groups uh it was mentioned that only I
think nine percent of people in the
state qualify for coverage for one of
these Services
um but remember we're only dealing with
individuals in small groups this is only
less than 25 percent of and the carriers
as far as I know Harvard Pilgrim
certainly does and I think all the other
people in the small group and the
individual Market already cover all
these so you're really trying to address
something that you to have no authority
over a Medicare Medicaid veterans Etc so
the answer is no nobody's done an
academic study on the external class I'm
not aware of anything but not my
expertise
fair enough okay
thank you very much thank you Mr
chairman okay uh Dr Dan from the
Chiropractic Association which
it's a very nice signature but I I don't
know what that last name is it parents
that's my best writing is that parent
parent yes okay so I did get it thank
you chairman and thank you all thank you
all for your time thank you for allowing
me to present today
um my name is Dr Daniel parent I am here
I am the vice president of the New
Hampshire Chiropractic Association I am
representing my colleagues and my
patients your constituents in regards to
my support for uh House Bill 303 I think
I'd like to focus on the 20 visit limit
um chairman Hyundai I believe you
spearheaded the 12 visit limit for us
back sometime uh I was in the room okay
I'm not sure
you actually voted for it because life
here was that a company might choose not
to cover Chiropractic anymore once we
mandated that 12 and sure enough Cigna
dropped it at the time
so that was my concern I understood
thank you well we appreciate your effort
on that just being in the room helped
thank you
um in regards to the 12 visit in my
practice of 28 years what I find
clinically is that people that come into
chronic are acute pain it takes
approximately 12 visits 10 8 10 12
visits to get them somewhat out of pain
and get them somewhat functional the
additional eight visits and that's
that's all this is asking for is an
additional eight which we're not asking
for uh extended period after that but
eight will allow us the time to help
them change lifestyle habits help them
incorporate postural exercises help them
utilize and incorporate lifestyle uh
things outside of the office to help
them stabilize their conditions so
they're not returning on a regular basis
with the same condition repeatedly over
and over and over again
I had something written out here but I'm
going to digress a little bit we talked
we didn't talk much about lifestyle we
did earlier
um two of the presenters talked about
lifestyle change and the upside down
pyramid and while we might have
additional drugs that might replace
opioids
I still believe we're going in the wrong
direction if we take a look at lifestyle
first
and while they may or may not be
evidence-based in regards to the
efficacy of yoga my patients who do yoga
on a regular basis and incorporate it
into their daily routine and lifestyle I
can guarantee you they're healthy I can
guarantee you they're healthy than those
who sit all day sorry
and listen to us okay Qigong the same
it's when we start to when we start to
give our patients the power to make
their own choices outside of our offices
but also give them options that they may
not be aware of
with yoga with Qigong with Chiropractic
with nutrition what are you going to do
for yourselves to help keep yourselves
out of
the system
because we know the system chases
symptoms we know it does nothing for the
most part to help them become healthy
and live their Lifestyles the way they
should or want to
I still believe that we're looking at
system from the wrong angle
now
I'm
in regards to evidence-based my question
is was there evidence-based research
that proved the efficacy and possibility
the possibility of even the
addictiveness of opioids
is there an evident evidence-based study
that proved those things
but they're still allowed to be put in
and where my cousin's 16 year old son
had a football injury in high school
and he's now dead
from overdosing I'm sure there was
evidence that said it's okay to give
this 16 year old injured athlete a drug
to mask his pain
but not to deal with his life and his
lifestyle and deal with the issues that
brought him in there in the first place
and and go towards the the issue itself
instead of masking it
you could no longer get opioids so he
ran to heroin
so
I don't think we're asking for much in
this bill I know these things have been
brought up before we talk about cost
Effectiveness in regard in regards to
Chiropractic we've been in front of this
committee numerous times showing
research after research after research
study that shows the cost effectiveness
of Chiropractic Care
and it's evidence-based value
yet it continues to get kicked down the
road
because costs seem to be the issue
I don't believe costs to be the issue
if you start incorporating lifestyle
concerns and giving people the power to
make their own choices outside of our
offices
you're going to see a change in the
system
yet we don't do that
here take this take it home
but continue to sit continue to eat what
you're eating don't exercise
don't meditate don't be mindful don't
okay it's our responsibility as
individuals to take care of ourselves
but I think we need a better system to
guide us because most don't know where
to go most don't know how to take care
of themselves we didn't come with it we
didn't come with a with a owner's manual
if you will this I believe has
spearheaded that
we need to start incorporating into our
society these types of things
hey
instead of relying on the same old same
old
which is guys this place in the first
place and if you want to talk about cost
Effectiveness keep doing the same thing
now costs continue to rise
the deductibles go up the co-pays go up
our premiums go up
so if we want to talk about cost
Effectiveness this isn't working because
our our
costs per person
continue to rise in regards to
healthcare
now that might be linked to business
that might be linked to other things as
well
but if we started educating our people
our constituents our patients on
alternatives to take care of themselves
better we might be in a different
situation
I thank you all that concludes my
testimony if anybody has any questions
please ask
thank you that was very compelling yeah
pharmacist
um
alternative medicine
um there are several
not doctors
um that will prescribe what you're
talking about how would an individual or
student or learn more about alternatives
to medication Tick Tock I'm just kidding
yeah
it sounds like if you don't go to a
chiropractor you don't really or know
someone that goes to a chiropractor
right you don't get that understanding
of alternative you know
um not medicine because I don't believe
it should be alternative medicine I
think it should be Alternative Care
right
where would that education come from
you've got to find it
you've got to find it the same thing
with teaching my adult children about
how to use their money and invest it
properly and not pay fees over fees over
fees you've got to find ways to do these
things
it's not it's it hasn't come to the
Forefront
it's not of the media
and I'll say that it's not on the media
doesn't teach it because they're funded
by people
that don't allow it to be taught
so for us it's right now as individuals
as practitioners in this room to support
this bill
it's up to us to do it and it's a small
group
but until this becomes mainstream we're
thank you thank you
thanks
oh we do have a question sorry
representative
I understand when you talk about going
from 12 visits to 20 visits in order to
get some maintenance and and and more
but this bill is down at the insurance
company level
how is that going to help
and many and several of the insurance
companies already talked about they
cover some of these things in various
different ways and that in fact the bill
is only going to cover 25 percent of
New Hampshire subscribers anyway because
Medicare Medicaid they won't cover it
right
do you think that the medical profession
itself
to inform people of these kinds of
things not insurance companies I'm not
clear on why the insurance company is
responsible for that as opposed to the
medical profession right that's where
I've learned everything from right
I think I think we took an oath to take
care of our people right but then what
this bill puts the onus on the insurance
company and the I I believe that the
bill puts some of the the onus which
again in regards to cost Effectiveness
in Chiropractic is very minimal
and we've proven that we've brought
those study to this to this committee
numerous times
um to answer your question in regards to
as a health care professional
it is our responsibility but I know a
lot of Health Care Professionals that
don't exercise in a daily basis
and I've watched what they've what they
eat and I watch how they don't get sleep
and meditate and be mindful and take
care of themselves and stretch and
so again goes back to the question how
do people know
some of the Physicians don't even know
you know and it it takes it's it's a
journey really I think for most and
you've got to figure out what works for
you and what doesn't work for you as an
individual
representative Burroughs thank you and I
I so would you believe I think that some
of this starts in medical school
um that I think a lot of physicians in
training and other people in the medical
profession are not
um given information they're not trained
in these other methodologies and
treatments so they don't they don't know
about them my husband is 72 years old is
a physician
um he couldn't get a class of nutrition
back in the day so I think some of that
falls on on educating these people who
are in the profession to do that yeah I
believe that too but in Chiropractic
College we didn't learn about meditation
yet I practice it every day you know we
didn't learn about well we did learn
about nutrition that actually learned a
lot about it but
um not as quite as well as I own it
today
you know so I think this still is still
a lot missing in education that could be
improved
um
but
if we can help our patients and
constituents and yourselves and
everybody's sitting behind me make
better choices
to hopefully stay out of a system
right that doesn't promote health and
well-being
thank you for um the chance to speak
briefly here
um
just making sure I'm muted I'm Sabrina
Dunlap I'm director of government
relations for anthem and I missed what
Harvard Pilgrim had to say I'm guessing
that we Echo a lot of
um what Peter said certainly Echo a lot
of what Heidi said I did want to just
emphasize that we were among the people
at the table for the like ad hoc
committee
um we're certainly open to conversation
we cover
a lot of services that are in the realm
of pain management I think the licensing
piece is key it's just a practical
problem that if you have a provider
that's not licensed there's no way to
really credential them and sort of bring
them under Clinical Services so it's not
that we're you know philosophically
opposed it's more of a practical issue
so
um I wanted to flag that and we do have
the board certified requirement in our
statute
so so yeah and just to reiterate we do
cover Chiropractic Services osteopathic
manipulative treatment acupuncture OTP
um it's really when you get into yoga
Qigong Tai Chi and meditation
um that those things are sort of outside
the clinical realm at this point so
um
anyway so that's all I have I'm happy to
answer any questions I'm sorry I'm
rushed
okay you might want to chance to ask
anthem
this is your chance
well thank you for the opportunity to
speak yeah yeah no problem
okay uh
uh I assume
the lady for the medical society did oh
great you're you're the other
I'm back and and I do apologize that I
missed a lot of the discussion I don't
want to be redundant tell us your name
I'm sorry your name uh said and Savage
yes
um and I am here to testify on behalf of
the New Hampshire Medical Society and I
am a pain medicine and addiction
medicine physician I've been practicing
in New Hampshire for almost 40 years I'm
no longer in clinical practice but I'm
still working in education
um within the Dartmouth Health System
I'm not
um uh testifying on behalf of Dartmouth
however just the medical society and
myself and
um I uh I am enthusiastic about this
bill because since the
um early 1980s I have been working to
try and integrate care and provide
multi-modal care of people with chronic
pain and uh and sometimes with
co-occurring addictive disorders
including opioid use disorder I have
served as director of an outpatient pain
service in an academic center I've been
privileged to work in the VA system for
was privileged to work for 14 years and
I had been medical director of a
residential treatment center that
actually was able to implement
multimodal intensive integrative care
and see patients come off of opioids and
in fact all medications and manage their
pain
um through active Lifestyle Changes
including medication meditation exercise
and other modalities so I've had a lot
of different perspectives on this and
it's from that that I I really do
support this work I've also had an
opportunity to serve as president of the
American pain society which has been an
interdisciplinary society that brings
together people from different
perspectives to treat pain and been in
advocacy for this
I think that this bill if it's passed
and I'm pleased to hear that most of the
people who are testifying on behalf of
it even the insurers like the spirit of
the bill but it's the details that are
hard to work out but from my perspective
if this bill class it will markedly
improve quality of life for people with
pain it will reduce Reliance and opioids
for the treatment of pain and I believe
that it will likely actually reduce
costs over the long run particularly for
people with chronic pain and why would
that happen well
um if we understand what pain is pain
whether it's acute such as surgical pain
or that associated with medical
illnesses or severe trauma whether it's
acute pain or whether it's chronic pain
due to Chronic conditions that perk
along or sometimes chronic pain we can't
identify the cause of the the pain the
the tissue cause of the pain what
whatever the pain is it is an experience
and it's shaped by very diverse
biological factors by environmental
factors psychological factors and social
factors so whatever the originating
cause usually in the tissue somewhere
that signal of of injury is sent through
the nervous system and it can be either
Amplified or it can be turned down or
inhibited at many points along the way
depending upon the chemical environment
in the body what drugs are present what
levels of certain Natural Body chemicals
like epinephrine or other other factors
are present it can be changed as it
travels through the brain by Thoughts by
Feelings by cognitions and then it
arrives that the brain is either very
severe or negligible depending upon how
it's been processed by the nervous
system and that's why we talk about
understanding the pain and and
active role in managing the pain because
there are things that individuals can do
to really change completely the nature
of pain
so we know that some people who have
serious tissue injury major trauma
surgical recovering from major surgeries
sometimes have little or no pain and
other people where we can't even find a
reason for the pain may experience
enormous pain and people who have
chronic pain it may vary from day to day
again depending upon contextual areas
how they're feeling and what behaviors
they're engaged in so these diverse the
diversity of
Shapers of pain contributors to pain
mean that in order to have an effective
pain treatment plan we really have to
help understand the contributors to that
experience of pain and then have a
really broad array of
tools that we can use for tailoring our
pain management pen to the particular
individual I usually think of our Tools
in large buckets and I think you've
heard most of these but
psycho-behavioral treatments such as
cognitive behavioral therapy mindfulness
there's a new one called pain re oh
recalibrating therapy where people
actually turn off the signals of pain
learn to turn off the signals of pain
there are physical approaches that we've
heard about physical therapy manual
therapies such as Chiropractic
osteopathic manipulation and movement
therapies we've been discussing and
importantly individualized exercise on a
regular basis the next third bucket
medications and it's not just opioids
but diverse classes of medications that
can be helpful and then finally the
interventionalist procedures which may
include injection therapies stimulators
and a variety of other things but no
single approach is right or even no set
of approaches is right for any
particular condition in any particular
individual it has to be individualized
we can't a priori decide what we're
going to provide
another key element though for chronic
pain as for most chronic pain chronic
conditions or diseases like
cardiovascular disease or diabetes is
engagement in the patient in
understanding the contributors to their
condition and in having an active role
in self-care of the condition this can
reduce symptoms it improves function and
improves quality of life and improves
the effectiveness of others treatments
so we don't just continue on long term
on multiple medications or keep going
back for more and more injections to get
palliative relief
we actually reduce the symptoms and are
able to manage the pain over time
so historically as you know we've heard
over and over today at least in the
beginning when I was still here I was
hearing insurers readily pay for
medications and procedures which are
often very expensive and often need to
be repeated or ongoing
um and for reasons that I've never
understood going back to the 1980s it's
much easier to get a series of very
expensive injections
approved than to get 10 sessions of
cognitive behavioral therapy with
mindfulness approved by a licensed
provider that might obviate the need
going forward for as much medication or
injections or May in fact lead to no use
of these other procedures
so
um I am not persuaded by the insurance
company the insurance Department's
fiscal analysis that says this bill will
increase cost just because it makes more
treatments available in fact my
expectation is that this bill would
reduce costs by allowing us more tools
to tailor
treatment to the individual's needs to
help coordinate that care because it
does ask for care coordination so that
it's implemented in a way that's most
helpful to the individual that we'd stop
in wasting Investments on just a limited
range of treatments that may be more
expensive and maybe less effective for
individuals
um and
um this bill will really allow us to
implement an effective individualized
treatment using a chronic disease
management model which study after study
after study has shown improve outcomes
for across different types of conditions
and quality of life for people with
chronic illnesses including chronic pain
and in many situations they reduce
Health Care utilization fewer trips to
the ER in crisis or to primary care or
to our hospitalizations
and less use of ongoing therapies with
greater engagement in in self-management
of the problem
so um this isn't just my perspective
virtually every organization that's
issued paying guidelines has supported a
multi-modal approach uh to paying care
that addresses the whole person is quite
simply the standard of care as I think
you've heard from many of the speakers
today and uh I've been doing this for 40
years and I'd be really excited to see a
change in the way we address pain in our
state I think we can do it and I thank
you very much and I'm very happy to
answer any questions but I think so many
have been asked and answered you may
have none left yes
representative spear has a question
this is a question I've asked already in
the in the past in this session and I
I've had pain incidences over my
lifetime as I'm sure many of us do I was
a very Avid jogger and so as a result my
hips don't work my knees don't work
and I go I've got been to all kinds of
doctors and
but I have never heard a doctor talk
about pain the way I've heard about a
talk today
why isn't the medical profession pushing
this as opposed to some individual
doctors but the medical profession
instead of trying to push the insurance
companies to solve the problem because
I've been to more kinds of doctors and
they never talk about it like this well
all I get is the usual typical stuff and
then they give up one of the things that
I've already heard I think you say or
someone saying this room is education is
a real problem we haven't historically
had a lot of Education in and on pain as
part of Core Medical Training nursing
training Pharmacy training or anything
else we hear about it the drugs that you
use for pain you get it in Pharma
Pharmacy but what is pain management
that hasn't been
um uh a course in itself or a focus in
itself you know
um and so that's part of the problem and
there is a big move within medical
education now to change that as it is
for addiction because we also didn't
have that that's another thing that
we've sorely needed
but the other thing is if it can't be
paid for we often don't pay attention
for it because most of our patients
can't afford to self-pay for things so I
think even doctors who are aware of the
opportunities
um for different approaches to treatment
don't know how to get them I think I
mentioned earlier you know I would be I
mean I remember
1986 or 7 doing epidurals and saying but
this isn't going to last unless I can
get this but the effects of this may be
helpful but unless I can get this person
exercising and managing their stress
it's not going to have any long-term
effects but it couldn't get a cognitive
behavioral Pain Group group set of group
sessions paid for
so I think you know we tend to prescribe
what we can what is realistic for the
patient so I think it's mutual I think
it has to be both I agree with you
entirely
thank you
okay thank you very much okay thank you
thank you for your testimony
um
personally this is uh the Prelude to my
question uh I find alternative uh
therapies uh very helpful
um
so
my question goes to the limiting factor
in the bill
um it seems very open-ended and so let
me explain what I mean by that
um
the definitional section uh talks about
behavioral interventions and then it
says including but not limited to and
then the manual treatments including but
not limited to movement therapies
including but not limited to so that's
very open-ended so I've been to
chiropractors that practice uh applied
kinesiology
I've been to chiropractors that practice
something called one brain therapy
which is maybe maybe you've never heard
of that I've been to acupuncturists that
practiced
the nambujra Pod allergy elimination
technique that's probably a pretty rare
one and then one one therapy that is
enlisted here that's helped me in the
past is something called the Alexander
technique
which isn't listed right so
um those were all attempts to experiment
um I didn't know if they were going to
be successful most of them weren't
um and so if we're going to raise
insurance rates by having an open-ended
mandate shouldn't the other uh the other
people paying into that pool
should should have a benefit to it as
well right they shouldn't be paying for
things that are
experimental that may not have any uh
efficacy and so again back to the
limiting factor question all these
including but not limit to statements
someone could put up a shingle
um that claims to be a pain therapy
modality and this spill I think as I
read it would mandate that that
paint that that uh service would be uh
have to be provided for because it's
pain therapy so what is the limiting
factor how do we determine what
something is effective at managing pain
I believe it says effective
evidence-based therapies
um and I think you know we can quibble
about what's evidence-based and what's
emerging evidence or evidence informed
but I think that's where the discussion
comes between the insurer and the
provider show me that this has shown
promise or has evidence and isn't just
you know the latest you know let's
experiment with this and and people
don't get better I'm sorry I didn't
articulate that very well but I think
um the discussion needs to be around
what
um whether something is evidence-based
or not whether it's demonstrated promise
of efficacy in the people and be whom
it's being used
just
for the question
so so if it's a mandate uh that we're
talking about here that we would need to
Define that in the legislation would you
agree
well I think
I think
what level of evidence has to be present
to call something evidence-based is open
to discussion I'm not sure that the
legislature can Define that I think that
might be a discussion for clinicians or
for the insurance department or for
others
um who who look at evidence
um but I'll give you an example it's
interesting one of the things that isn't
mentioned in here is that emerging pain
treatment that I mentioned and Dave you
may know the name of it but it's um pain
restructuring therapy or it's changing
cognition so that at the neurologic
level you can block the pain with your
brain there's a new therapy out it has
now four or five papers supporting its
use
um and they're more larger trials
underway whether that would yet be
considered evidence-based I'm not 100
sure that's open to discussion but
that's the kind of thing that might five
years from now be named in here but it
isn't yet because it's an emerging
therapy with promise of efficacy do you
see
but I agree with you you can't pay for
everything you need to have some
evidence that it's helpful
okay
thank you I have two more cards yet left
oh I'm sorry
well uh usually what I do is at the end
I'll let you come up and clean up
good afternoon good afternoon
thank you for allowing me to have a few
moments to speak and I appreciate the
fact that you guys have been sitting
here all afternoon and dealing with many
many bills
um the reason I am here is going to
probably sound like a unique and
interesting one and probably one that
you didn't expect but I appreciate all
of the work that has been done on this
bill I believe that this is an
opportunity for the State of New
Hampshire to start small and work up to
actually covering a larger variety of
groups and categories by starting with
this Bill
I'm here because
one of the things that was not brought
up in this bill and one of the groups
that was not consulted or considered
while drafting this bill is the
therapeutic cannabis community of the
State of New Hampshire we currently have
over 12 000 patients I believe actually
it's closer to 14 000 plus now and out
of that 70 percent of those patients are
actually on the program for pain chronic
pain related issues of that we have 50
percent uh 70 percent
are for
severe pain 50 are for chronic pain and
20 are for other degrees of severe pain
in magnitude uh this bill should be
amended to include therapeutic cannabis
has an alternative treatment
whether that be in regards to
individuals getting the
plant access to the plant that they need
or whether that be having appointments
for therapeutic cannabis covered in the
state currently this is not covered At
All by insurance this is an
out-of-pocket cost that can be
it's huge for patients
um you know you you are looking at
anywhere from
eight thousand dollars a year to over
twenty five thousand dollars a year out
of pocket depending on the severity of
your condition and what it is you
require in order to successfully
integrate back into a healthy lifestyle
this has a direct impact on individuals
and a lot of times patients are left
having to make decisions on whether they
treat their health or whether they're or
not they pay their bills
you know
I've I've gone through this myself
um you know what what good is it for me
to you know be able to pay this bill if
on my will say my car what good is it
for me to pay the insurance and pay the
maintenance on my vehicle if I'm not
physically capable of driving that
vehicle because I can't afford the
medication that I need each month that
allows my body to function
um you know we see a lot of individuals
that are put in those situations I
realize that this bill does not cover a
huge group of individuals in the state
but as I seated this is an opportunity
to start small and hopefully create a
trend that we see graduate to cover more
and more individuals throughout the
state I don't see this as being a huge
issue in regards to how we cover it or
how an insurance company deals with it
because fortunately
therapeutic cannabis has probably some
of the strictest regulations in the
state of New Hampshire as far as how the
program is run and operated which would
make it extremely easy to work with
insurance companies in order to be able
to help patients and to get coverage
that they need for this
I realized that there is still a lot of
stigma and even discrimination in
regards to therapeutic cannabis use in
the state but that needs to not be an
issue right now just because a person
chooses an alternative method for health
care they should not be discriminated
against having coverage for their health
care choices and leaving therapeutic
cannabis off of this bill
does that
um I have had the pleasure to sit on the
therapeutic cannabis medical oversight
board as the patient representative for
the State of New Hampshire we have had a
listening session we have spoken to
patients we have spoken with
dispensaries we have you know gone above
and beyond in trying to find out what it
is our patients need and the number one
issue that is always raised is
affordability
this bill if therapeutic cannabis is
added to it allows the beginning of that
to start taking place so that more and
more individuals can receive some sort
of financial relief they can pursue
their quality of life and they can have
control over their health care
I have not unfortunately
had very good luck when it comes with my
own health care and using modern
medications and modern medicine
I was very lucky to be introduced to
therapeutic cannabis and as a result I
walked in this room by myself I can sit
here and speak to all of you and address
all of you
and I can take care of my children and
my family before I found therapeutic
cannabis the only options I was given
were opioids or surgery that had a very
high chance of leaving me in even worse
conditions than what I already was I had
to use canes sometimes I couldn't even
pull myself up to walk
I I don't necessarily hold that against
the medical professionals but I do think
that insurance companies and medical
professionals sometimes maybe tie their
own hands when it comes to exploring
alternative treatment options for their
patients
you know I am very fortunate to live a
much better lifestyle than I did I wish
that there were more options for
a patient to be able to have some sort
of financial relief and I would really
like this committee to take that
opportunity to make a change to do
something as a first and to amend this
representative Burroughs
yeah and I'll admit I just looked this
up but um I think one of the problems
that we may have at the state level is
that this is still a schedule one drug
at the federal level and which may make
it very difficult for any state to um to
allow insurance to cover it so that
might might have to be dealt with it
there before we can we can do that
and to that I would respond with that
there has been a memo that has been
issued for several years even during the
Trump Administration even during the
Biden Administration that says a state
is allowed to do as they choose in
regards to therapeutic cannabis and that
the federal government will not stand in
their way
and this is an opportunity we do not
have the federal government storming New
Hampshire
and reading our dispensaries or
incarcerating our patients
you know this is an opportunity to do
something in regards
to making a change
follow-up please for the question you
mean Claire yeah and you know I I'm
actually all in favor of of
um insurance coverage
um this just so you know but I I think
it would be worthy to find out why
um despite the fact that it's legal in
37 states that insurance is not covering
it I think that might be the next step
who knows
the world of marijuana is uh
who knows how far they're gonna let us
go
get any other questions
Vicki Irwin
okay so I'll go with last but not least
that's it all right I won't keep you
long um as you said my name is Vicki
Irwin I am a licensed acupuncturist here
in the state of New Hampshire I am a
member of the New Hampshire acupuncture
and Asian medicine Association although
I am not representing them today and I'm
also the new chairperson for the back um
Board of acupuncture licensing so I kind
of wanted to introduce myself as a put
some names with some faces and I'd love
to be a sounding board for folks later
although technically today I am
testifying as a professional not on
behalf of the licensing board
um but I did want to take a moment to
thank all of you for listening all day
today and to the committee members that
had worked so hard behind the scenes to
put this bill together my predecessor
Cindy tyrogetti tried to bring me up to
speed on this as well as hb66 which is
not today's topic of discussion but
something I'm excited to see coming down
the line as well
so I'm excited to see this bill to come
together I do own and operate
Acupuncture Center of Southern New
Hampshire out of Nashua New Hampshire
and I perform better than 1700
treatments a year most of these are on
folks with chronic pain a handful of
them are actually recovering addicts
that are just looking for an alternative
to their an alternative to pain
medications unfortunately so many of
those folks are lacking adequate
insurance coverage for Alternatives like
myself
um but I do direct Bill insurance
companies whenever I can the vast
majority of my practice is in fact
Insurance uh billing
um I have a small handful of prompt pay
folks or or self-pay folks and I enjoy
seeing them but uh insurance is the bulk
of my business while I'm grateful to see
a growing number of insurance policies
that do offer some acupuncture benefits
I watch my patients carefully budgeting
their visits or their units that they're
allowed for the year to try to stretch
them out over the course of the year
and I really think they're um lifestyle
or quality of life would be greatly
improved even by adding just a few
additional visits per year like the 20
that this bill is asking for a lot of my
folks have kind of in the 10 to 12 range
I can usually get them feeling a whole
lot better but then they drop off
because they've run out of benefits and
a year later their back saying so I was
feeling great but now I don't
and we're sort of starting over from
scratch in a manner of speaking I
actually think allowing a few extra
visits with me would be much more
advantageous to the insurance companies
then sending them to somebody like our
colleague Dr Nagel
a 3 500 shot for heaven's sakes you
um the average amount that I built out
for two sets of needles is 117 for a one
hour visit
that's a lot of shots
um at any rate
um
I do believe that increasing the
coverage and a nice multimodal approach
like this bill is calling for uh would
benefit individuals in pain a great deal
and also has the potential to decrease
the burden of opioid addiction that the
state is currently condemning with so I
thank you for your time and I'm happy to
I guess we're all questioned out I guess
so all right thank you thank you
okay representative you can wrap it up
right because that's that's really yeah
gonna turn your mic on
because that is the reasoning I mean uh
in terms of we actually even have
another requirement that you have to be
you know board certified but then we
back off on that when we go so I I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna challenge you by
asking you what your understanding of
evidence-based medicine is but I uh in
my book there's a subsection called
evidence-based Edison myths and
realities because when I started looking
at it I didn't I it turned out I didn't
have a clue what it was so I went on
asked my colleagues and I the number of
doctors who actually knew what
evidence-based medicine is was like
close to zero and and so I don't expect
the insurers to be any better but what
what what it is it's the use of the
entire body of the medical literature is
applied to the individual circumstances
of a patient so we're getting back to
this patient-centered thing a couple
years ago there was a gentleman who
apparently had nothing better to do than
he looked at a thousand medical
questions that were in the Cochrane
collection which is the largest
collection of evidence based in the
world on medical questions he found out
that only three percent of medical
questions were answered beyond a shadow
of a doubt which means 97 percent of the
questions in medicine are not answered
sufficiently
my concern is this and we brought this
up at the ad hoc group when that issue
came up before I don't mind using the
evidence we have to try to do the best
we can to say what works and what
doesn't but what I do demand is that we
use a Level Playing Field in doing that
for example
surgeons use pedicle screws on a regular
basis to do spinal fusions there is
virtually no evidence to support that
practice for the in the degenerative
spine at all I hate to imagine how much
money we spend every year to pay for
that
but then when we have uh the ACT there's
a blanket on the name of it there's an
acupuncture thing that looked at the
evidence on 107 acupuncture 117
conditions and found that it was valid
for that well when they were struggling
to to approve that we're not dealing
with a Level Playing Field so all I want
the insurers to do is say you know what
we're going to use the same system of
analysis for acupuncture chiropractic
massage which are all done by licensed
therapists as we would for a spinal
surging doing
um
you know a pedicle screw fixation or me
Dave Nagel doing one of his 63 000
epidurals which for example there is
virtually no evidence to support any
long-term efficacy of an epidural
steroid injection unless you combine it
with another modality the only paper
that ever showed efficacy was in 1998
and they used epidural injections with a
combined approach of behavioral therapy
and physical therapies was all three
things together not just one so that's
what I'm asking for you guys and you
know that we've talked about that before
and I think that when you use that term
it's really important you know what
we're talking about I don't even see it
in the bill anyway so it's not but
everybody's you you're right you're
right so I wasn't going to go but no I
think the um
the big issue in all these years that
I've been sitting here on this committee
is
um is when they what I would interpret
the evidence base when they're saying is
eminent base is that there were some uh
studies in which you had a control group
right and you know how few of those
those are those randomized all I know is
that that's what they you know they want
they want is to you know
most of the you want placebos involved
most of the studies that I've ever used
to support what I do George Eng you
don't know George angler doesn't matter
so
um he's an important person trust me but
anyways he said was my personal
experience and my and that but the other
thing is a lot of times it's just some
letter to the editor that changes the
way everybody does everything you know
that's scheduled D evidence it's not
schedule a evidence so anyways I'm done
it's great thank you very much
uh I hope you feel like we you've got a
good hearing
good
all right for the members uh I Paula did
you have a handout
and uh sorry about this I'll take you so
so uh we are going to be you know
getting closer to doing our subcommittee
so please now that you've heard all
kinds of different kinds of bills make
sure you let me know which subcommittee
you would like to be on because I I want
to get that put to bed fairly soon
otherwise
um have a have a great weekend because
we're not coming in tomorrow
and I'm just um wanted to mention I'm
Paula minahan I think I met you last
week and I didn't have this packet
available but I just wanted you to take
it home and review it it has some
interesting information about your
hospitals in the state and my card is
here and I'm happy to answer any
questions that you may have about any of